Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Ich begrüße alle hier zur 118. Ausgabe von Raumzeit und heute bin ich mal wieder
auf Reisen gegangen und habe mich nach Bremen begeben, Um ja mal ein Thema auf die Liste zu holen,
was so ein bisschen noch am Seitenrand stand die ganze Zeit.
Konkret soll es nämlich heute gehen um die Einbindung der Industrie in die Raumfahrt.
Da wo also die Maschinen nicht nur gestaltet, sondern eben auch konkret gebaut werden.
Ja und da begrüße ich erstmal meine Gesprächspartnerin für heute, Charlotte Burg.
Hi.
Hallo Charlotte, wunderbar. Wir sind in Bremen und zwar ganz konkret sind wir
hier bei OHB, ein Name, den man in der Raumfahrt kennt.
Sicherlich kein Unternehmen, was so eine deutschlandweite Resonanz hat,
aber natürlich in der Raumfahrt bekannt ist wie ein bunter Hund.
Ursprünglich hieß das mal Otto Hydraulik Bremen GmbH.
Das stimmt. Und dann hieß es mal orbitale Hochtechnologie Bremen und mittlerweile
haben wir nur noch die Buchstaben, glaube ich, OHB ohne Bedeutung.
Ja, genau. Ja, ich glaube in der Raumfahrt sind wir sehr bekannt.
Wir sind drittgrößte Satellitenbauunternehmen in Europa.
Aber ich glaube auch in Bremen kennt man uns sehr gut, sehr wohl.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Wir haben viele Mitarbeiter hier, aber sonst haben wir nicht so die Prominenz
wie jetzt Airbus oder so, wo man ja auch die Flugzeuge vor allem kennt.
Das machen wir nämlich nicht. Wir machen reine Raumfahrt.
Aber klein ist der Standort ja nicht. Also wenn ich das richtig sehe,
sind das so knapp 3000 Mitarbeiter.
Das ist ja schon ein etwas größerer mittelständischer Betrieb kann man sagen.
Absolut. Wir sind auch stark gewachsen. Ich bin seit zehn Jahren in der Firma
und als ich hierher kam, waren es ein paar hundert.
Genau wie viele weiß ich nicht mehr, aber wir sind stark gewachsen in den letzten zehn Jahren.
Also wir haben ja hier so einen Standort, ich glaube, auch in der Nähe der Universität
in Bremen und auch in der Nähe von anderen wichtigen Raumfahrtnahen, Instituten,
wissenschaftlichen Organisationen, der Fallturm ist glaube ich nicht weit.
Das war ja sicherlich eine bewusste Entscheidung, sich hier einzubetten.
Ja, das war vor meiner Zeit, aber ich finde es passt sehr gut.
Wir sind ein Unternehmen, wir sind stark an Forschung, Entwicklung,
Wissenschaft dran und darum hier oben im Technologiepark in der Nähe der Uni,
in der Nähe vom DLR und Zahm hattest du ja auch eben angesprochen,
das ist ein super Standort.
So, stellt sich natürlich erstmal die Frage, was hat dich denn hier hingeführt?
Du bist ja, glaube ich, Luft - und Raumfahrttechnikerin, wenn ich das richtig
sehe. So eine Ausbildung, die hast du wo gemacht?
Ich habe in Berlin studiert, an der TU Berlin habe ich Luft - und Raumfahrttechnik
studiert, habe dann einen Master in Space Engineering and Astronautics gemacht in England,
in Cranfield University und danach habe ich einen PhD gemacht in Glasgow an
der Strathclyde University und mein Fokus da war, nennt er sich,
Habe ich vergessen? Nein. Quatsch. Space Mission Applications of High Area to
Mass Ratio Orbital Dynamics.
Wow, that's a mouthful.
Ja.
Heißt? Also es geht um Körper mit einem großen Oberfläche -zu -Masse -Verhältnis,
die im Weltraum, also im Orbit sich befinden.
Und dadurch, dass die Oberfläche so groß ist, erfahren sie überproportional
viel Oberflächenkräfte, wie zum Beispiel Sonnendruck, ganz genau,
Solardruck, aber halt auch Drag zum Beispiel.
Und wir hatten geschaut, was passiert mit diesen Objekten, wie verhalten die sich?
Und dann haben wir oder habe ich Anwendungen definiert. Und eine Anwendung,
die da rauskam, war, dass man auch aus sehr hohen zirkulären Orbits mithilfe
des Solardrucks passiv den Wiedereintritt forcieren kann,
wenn man seine Oberfläche gezielt zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt ändert.
Sprich, man hat zum Beispiel einen Ballon dabei, den man zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt,
genauen Zeitpunkt, bevor er berechnet ist, aufbläst.
Und dann sorgt der Solardruck dafür, dass das Perigeum des Orbits,
also das ist der Punkt, der der Erde am nächsten ist, immer näher zur Erdoberfläche
kommt, weil der Orbit insgesamt elliptischer wird.
Und dann, wenn der dann niedrig genug ist, dann hat er dort so viel Luftwiderstand,
dass der ganze Satellit wieder eintritt.
Da bin ich auch in diese Weltraumschrott -Thematik reingegangen.
Jedenfalls mein Fokus war eben Orbitaldynamik, war sehr mathematisch orientiert.
Und dann habe ich, nachdem ich mein PhD abgeschlossen hatte oder ich habe noch
meine, meine Arbeit war noch nicht geschrieben, aber meine Forschung war zu Ende,
da habe ich mich umgeschaut nach möglichen Stellen und habe hier eine ganz ansprechende
Stelle gefunden bei ORB, nämlich Systemingenieurin in der Vorentwicklung.
Und und hab mich beworben und hab die Stelle bekommen. Das ist jetzt über zehn
Jahre her und seitdem bin ich hier bei OHB in Bremen in der Vorentwicklung und
mittlerweile, also von Systemingenieurin, leitende Systemingenieurin,
bin ich mittlerweile Abteilungsleiterin und Projektmanagerin.
Für welche Abteilung genau?
Wissenschaftsmissionen.
Wissenschaftsmissionen, was ein Schwerpunkt ist bei OHB, kann man sagen.
Okay, spannend. Also das deutet ja auch schon ein anderes Thema an,
auf das wir sicherlich noch mal eingehen, aber so dieser Wiedereintritt,
das ist natürlich ein heißes Thema seit einigen Jahren in der Raumfahrt,
weil das halt einfach mal mit eingepreist werden muss.
Dass es im Prinzip ja auch ein Memorandum of Understanding gibt.
Von Gesetzen kann man ja nicht wirklich sprechen, sozusagen das ist das Ziel,
möglichst wenig Schrott zu hinterlassen, weil wir haben halt schon genug im
All wie auf der Erde und da gibt es ja einige Jahre nachzuarbeiten,
wo der Fokus nicht so sehr darauf lag, wie man den Ort wieder verlässt und vor
allem nicht so verlassen hat, wie man ihn vorzufinden wünscht.
Absolut, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, genau.
Aber deine Technik war so ein bisschen das rausfinden, weil man den Regenschirm
im richtigen Moment aufspannt, um ein bisschen sich abzubremsen.
Ja, das war total spannend, weil ich hatte vorher viele Paper gelesen,
natürlich ein Literature Review gemacht und so weiter und ich bin halt immer
wieder darauf gestoßen,
den Luftwiderstand zu nutzen, aber das geht nur bis maximal 800 Kilometer,
weil danach wird es zu wenig Luftwiderstand, keine Restatmosphäre und dann muss
man sich anders behelfen.
Und dann in meinen Simulationen habe ich dann gesehen, das geht ja,
man kann ja viel höher noch die Oberfläche nutzen, eben durch den Solardruck
und also 3000 Kilometer zum Beispiel gab es eine Zone, in der es möglichst effektiv
ist, 6000 Kilometer in dem Bereich.
Und dann war das für mich eine totale Überraschung, dass das vorher noch nicht
so richtig aufgetaucht ist und genutzt wurde.
Das würde mich mal interessieren.
Wenn ich jetzt richtig zurückrechne, diese Studienzeit muss ungefähr so 2010 herum so gewesen sein.
Bist ja jetzt mal ein etwas modernerer Student im Vergleich zu vielen alten
Hasen, die ich hier schon interviewt habe.
Kannst du uns mal so ein bisschen Einblick geben, weil ich finde es immer herausfordernd,
gerade wenn man in so einem wissenschaftlichen, technisch -wissenschaftlichen
Bereich unterwegs ist, sich einen Überblick zu verschaffen.
Ich meine, auf der einen Seite muss man sich erstmal die ganze Mathematik und
das Basiswissen und so weiter natürlich auf jeden Fall ranholen,
aber man will ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch auf dem Stand der Dinge sein und
die akkumulieren sich natürlich über die Jahre.
Das Wissen wird ja nicht komplett verworfen, sondern es kommt halt immer wieder
was dazu. Wie hast du da den Weg gefunden, wirklich festzustellen, da fehlt was?
Also hast du irgendwie moderne Recherchemethoden verwendet, zum Beispiel,
um irgendwie Paper im großen Stil abzugrasen oder muss man einfach nur viel
lesen oder sich für intuitiv an das Richtige heranrobben?
Hast du da irgendwie einen Pfad, den man empfehlen kann?
Also erst mal habe ich mich auf diese freie Forschungsstelle beworben,
die war aber vom Ziel her schon definiert, also es ging eben um High Area -to
-Mass -Ratio Orbital Dynamics.
Mein Professor, das war Professor Colin McInnes, kennt sich sehr gut in dem
Bereich aus und der wusste eben, da gibt es noch freie Stellen,
Sachen, unbeantwortete Fragen anzuschauen.
Das heißt, so ganz ist das natürlich nicht nur auf meinem Mist gewachsen.
Und als ich dann dort angefangen habe, war ich erst mal sehr breit aufgestellt.
Ich habe gesagt, okay, jetzt erst mal simuliere ich, was passiert überhaupt
bei dem Oberflächensache. Das ist was, was viele Leute vor mir auch schon gemacht haben.
Und dann immer, wenn ich an eine Stelle gekommen bin, wo ich es interessant
fand oder so, habe ich immer gesucht nach Papern, die...
Sich auch dem widmen und dann dort wirklich ganz klassisch über die Referenzliste
auf andere Papers gestoßen und so weiter und so weiter.
Und dann, als die ersten Ergebnisse da waren, das war schon innerhalb von einem
Jahr, bin ich dann auf Konferenzen gegangen.
Und da habe ich meine Arbeit vorgestellt und auch dort wurde ich dann wieder
von Leuten angesprochen, die gesagt haben, hast du mal die Arbeit von das und
das und das und dem und dem angeschaut.
Das ist doch ähnlich, da gibt es doch Schnittstellen und so ist das passiert.
Also es gab keine sehr modernen Methoden.
Ich glaube, das sind die Methoden, die schon vor 100 Jahren in der Wissenschaft so verwendet wurden.
Okay, also funktioniert noch und hat sozusagen auch noch seine Berechtigung.
Das ist auch gut zu wissen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, dann schauen wir doch mal, was OHB jetzt hier eigentlich macht.
Also wenn man jetzt so Missionen vorstellt, und ich habe ja hier viele Missionen
schon vorgestellt, Sowohl die wissenschaftlichen Aspekte, vielleicht mal mit
mehr Fokus auf die Instrumente,
aber natürlich dann auch die eigentliche Missionssteuerung, Launch,
all diese ganzen Aspekte, da kommt ja eine Menge dazu.
Haben wir meistens immer so ein Segment, wo wir kurz darüber sprechen,
so okay, warum gibt's denn das überhaupt?
So ja, da hat die ESA dann irgendwann mal beschlossen und dann haben wir das halt gebaut.
Und das fasst ja eigentlich eine ganze Menge zusammen, weil da gehört ja dann
erstmal das Spüren der Notwendigkeit für ein bestimmtes Thema auf der einen Seite,
wissenschaftlicher Unterbau, der hier irgendwie gegeben sein muss,
dann eine entsprechende Diskussion bis hin zu Machbarkeitsstudien,
was ist denn jetzt hier sozusagen überhaupt zu machen.
Jetzt seid ihr ja hier, ein Teil davon.
Wie schlagen solche Themen bei euch auf?
Also ab wann ist überhaupt OHB an so etwas beteiligt?
Kannst du uns vielleicht mal erstmal so einen groben Ablauf geben,
wie so eine Mission insgesamt vom Zeitrahmen abläuft?
Ja klar. Also ganz allgemein bei Raumfahrtmissionen unterscheidet man ja zwischen
den verschiedenen Phasen, die fast alle Buchstaben haben, außer eine Zahl.
Das ist Phase 0 und dann A, B, C, D, E.
Wir sind hier in der Vorentwicklung normalerweise für die Phasen 0, A und B1 zuständig.
Phase 0 ist eine Art Vorstudie, wo man wirklich ganz grob die Konzepte für eine
Idee generiert. Phase A ist die Machbarkeitsstudie, wo man am Ende mit einem
Missionskonzept rauskommt.
Und Phase B1 ist die erste Detailausarbeitung, wo man am Ende den sogenannten
Preliminary Requirements Review hat.
Und da werden die Anforderungen an die Mission nochmal durchleuchtet und es
wird entschieden, mit welchen Anforderungen geht man jetzt in die richtige Detailarbeit. Das heißt...
Die Anforderungen kommen ja immer von irgendwoher. Die Anforderungen kommen
in der Wissenschaftsmission von den Wissenschaftlern.
Die Wissenschaftler identifizieren, sie möchten irgendetwas untersuchen und
sagen dann, wir brauchen dafür Daten in dem und dem Spektralwand oder mit der
und der Frequenz und der Genauigkeit und so weiter.
Also richtige Datenanforderungen erstmal nur an das, was wir das Science Product
nennen und das Wissenschaftsprodukt.
Also meistens die Instrumente, die dann sozusagen auf dem Satelliten installiert sind.
Genau, aber man kann sagen Anforderungen an das Gesamtsystem Satellit,
aber dann würde man aus diesen Anforderungen an das Datenprodukt,
würde man als erstes Anforderungen an das Instrument ableiten können und wenn
man dann weiß, wie das Instrument aussieht, dann weiß man, was man dafür für
einen Satelliten braucht, damit man das fliegen kann.
Aber diese Schritte, also die Wissenschaftler selber, haben meistens gar nicht
die Möglichkeit, das abschätzen zu können, was bedeutet das für den Satelliten,
wie schwer wird der, wie teuer wird der vor allem.
Und da unterstützen wir. Und das machen wir in dem ersten Schritt meistens pro bono.
Also wir sind dann mit Wissenschaftlern im Gespräch und sagen, wir helfen euch, eure,
Wissenschaftsanforderungen runterzubrechen und daraus ein erstes ganz grobes
Systemdesign zu machen. Und das könnt ihr dann benutzen, um gegenüber ESA,
das ist meistens ESA, einen Science -Vorschlag einzureichen,
also einen Missionsvorschlag.
Und dann, wenn wir das machen, weil sowas springt für uns dabei raus,
wir haben dann schon sehr früh Einblicke in kommende Missionen.
Und das ist also was, was wir total gerne auch machen und es macht auch Spaß.
Man ist im Gespräch, man zeigt auch, was man drauf hat.
Das auch, genau. Und wir haben dann gute Connections zu den Wissenschaftlern irgendwo.
Letztendlich, wenn man erstmal… Ich glaube, das würde auch mit einer finanziellen
Basis überhaupt nicht funktionieren, weil wo soll die Wissenschaftler das in der Phase hernehmen?
Ganz genau. Und aber jetzt auch nochmal persönlich gesprochen,
macht auch einfach wahnsinnig Spaß, weil man dann auch sehr,
sehr frei ist in der Konzeptionierung.
Man hat noch gar keine Design -Requirements. Design Requirements sind die,
die dann später kommen, die das spezielle Design irgendwie festlegen,
wo man dann eingeengt wird in seiner Wahl.
Und da sind wir noch ganz frei und das macht besonders viel Spaß.
Klar, da kann man richtig rumspinnen.
Ja, so ist es wirklich.
Was wäre wenn?
Ja, und das ist echt richtig cool. Und dann müssen wir natürlich ein bisschen
gucken, passt das in den Budgetrahmen rein, der jetzt angedacht ist und versuchen
auch den Wissenschaftlern zu helfen, diesen einzuhalten, wenn es nicht geht.
Also wenn wir merken, okay, das wird viel zu schwer, viel zu teuer oder sowas,
dann sagen wir, okay, was wäre, wenn wir stattdessen das und das und das machen?
Und am Ende wollen wir halt was haben, was auch Hand und Fuß hat.
Und das reichen dann die Wissenschaftler bei der ESA ein.
Und dann ist eigentlich unser direkter Kontakt zu den Wissenschaftlern erst
mal vorbei. Dann läuft das in der ESA.
Die nehmen diese verschiedenen Missionsvorschläge und suchen dann,
evaluieren die und suchen dann welche aus. Also ganz konkret läuft jetzt gerade zum Beispiel der M7.
M7 ist eigentlich die siebte Science -M -Class -Mission, also mittlere Mission mittlerer Größe.
M6 wurde aber ausgelassen, also es ist eigentlich die sechste.
Es gab aber M1, M2, M3, M4 und M5.
Also M7, da sind wir gerade… Was waren das für Missionen, um mal einen Vergleich
zu haben, was Mittel ist?
Ja, also Solar Orbiter ist eine. Dann haben wir Plato bei uns,
wird gerade gebaut bei OHB, das ist eine Exoplaneten -Finde -Mission.
Dann Ariel zum Beispiel ist auch so eine astronomische Mission.
Und genau bei, jetzt Envision ist der Kandidat für M5, das ist eine Mission
zur Venus, eine Radar -Mission zur Venus.
Und jetzt M7 sind wir im Moment noch bei fünf möglichen Kandidaten und davon
wird ESA jetzt in den nächsten Wochen drei auswählen, die in die nächste Runde gehen.
Und ab dem Punkt, wo dann noch drei über sind, da wird die Industrie wieder involviert.
Das heißt, dann bittet uns ESA, Angebote für Studien abzugeben, und zwar Phase A und B1.
Und dann wird für alle drei Missionen jeweils zwei parallele Studien durchgeführt
für diese Phase A, also diese Machbarkeitsstudie und diese Missionskonzeptstudie.
Und am Ende davon möchte ESA von uns wissen, was sind die Risiken, was sind die Kosten.
Welche Requirements, also welche Anforderungen können erreicht werden,
also wie hochperformant kann dieses System sein und darum auch mit zwei parallelen
Industriekonsortien, damit man eben eine Art Zweitmeinung dabei hat.
Und dann auf dieser Basis von dem Ergebnis von der Phase A wird dann in zwei
Jahren die tatsächliche Mission ausgewählt, die es dann wird.
Und das ist wahnsinnig spannend, weil die Missionen so interessant sind im wissenschaftlichen Bereich.
Also wenn wir jetzt bei M7 gucken, was ist noch im Rennen, kann man auch im
Internet recherchieren, aber es gibt eine Mission mit zwei Orbitern am Mars.
Es gibt eine Mission, die soll auf dem Zwergplaneten Ceres landen.
Es gibt eine Mission, wo es eine Hauptspacecraft und viele Töchter -Spacecraft
gibt, die in Formation fliegen und das Erdplasma erforschen.
Es gibt ein Gamma -Ray Observatory und es gibt noch eine astroseismologische
Mission. Also wahnsinnig spannende.
Auch sehr breit gestreut. Total. Schwierig da überhaupt einen Schwerpunkt festzulegen.
Aber ich glaube vor den Entscheidungen steht die ESA ja am laufenden Meter da.
Richtig.
Da weinen immer mehr als sich freuen. Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Okay. Ich habe jetzt drei Phasen gehört. Also eine einzelne Mission,
wenn sie denn dann wirklich mal gebaut und geflogen wird, bis zu wie vielen
Buchstaben geht das dann noch?
Also genau, B1 ist normalerweise die letzte Phase, die wir in der Vorentwicklung
machen. Danach gibt es dann ein Angebot, die Mission auch wirklich zu implementieren.
Und dann gehen wir ab an die Implementierungsdirektorate hier und dort kommt
dann B2. Das ist das Detailed Design.
Das endet dann mit dem Preliminary Design Review, PDR.
Dann kommt die Phase C, da wird auch schon gebaut, da kommt dann das Critical Design Review am Ende.
Und dann die Phase D ist wirklich Assembly, Integration und Testing.
Dann wird das ganze Spacecraft zusammengeschraubt, komplett getestet.
Und in der Phase E, das ist Operations,
da wird es dann gelauncht und der Satellitenbetrieb ist da auch dabei.
Und dann spricht man manchmal noch von der Phase F, das Disposal,
das kommt wieder dann in diesen Bereich Space debris mitigation.
Okay, also im Prinzip geht es von Null bis F.
Genau.
Nur, okay, interessant, das ist
B1, B2 und genau da ist aber auch so eine Trennung der Zuständigkeiten.
Fragen Sie mich, warum da nicht einfach die Buchstaben weitergeführt wurden?
Ja, das ist ganz interessant. Also eigentlich ist Phase B das,
wo die Requirements konsolidiert werden und das Design quasi komplett gemacht wird.
Das ist theoretisch immer alles auf dem Papier und noch nichts gekauft und dann
ab Phase C wird gekauft und so weiter.
In der Realität ist es nicht ganz so, aber der Schnitt hier ist bis zum B1 -Ende.
Kann man das als Systemintegrator mit seinen Unterauftragnehmern gemeinsam das Design machen.
Danach muss man anfangen mit den Komponenten, Manufacturing,
die Verträge abzuschließen. Und da muss man dann auch den Vertrag mit dem Kunden
haben, weil sonst kann man das nicht weitergeben.
Also darum ist da meistens der Schnitt. Aber es gibt tatsächlich auch Ausnahmen.
Wir hatten ja Comet Interceptor.
Das war eine Science Mission, die wir jetzt gewonnen haben. Also in Italien,
UAB Italien wird die implementieren. Wir sind aber auch dabei.
Und da wurde es mal ganz anders gemacht. Das war für uns auch ein Novum.
Da haben wir nämlich zwei Phasen, Phase 1 und Phase 2.
Und Phase 1 ist Phase A, B1 und B2.
Und wir haben damals also tatsächlich bis zum Ende der Phase B2 in der Vorentwicklung
an dieser Mission gearbeitet.
Also bis zum detaillierten Design.
Richtig, bis zum Ende des detaillierten Designs.
Ok, also ist auch nicht in Stein gemeißelt, aber im Prinzip ist das so eine
Art Gerüst, mit dem man schnell kommunizieren kann, wo befindet sich jetzt so ein Projekt.
Ja, ok. Würde ich ganz gerne nochmal in die einzelnen Phasen vielleicht ein
bisschen reinschauen, weil ich glaube das ist ja dann auch für eure tägliche
Arbeit dann auch sehr aussagekräftig.
Weiß nicht, könnte man sich jetzt mal an einem konkreten Projekt ja vielleicht auch orientieren.
Also Null, die Nullphase, wer nimmt da mit wem erst mal Kontakt auf,
womit fängt's an, wer ruft wen an?
Im Science -Bereich läuft die Phase Null meistens bei der ESAB,
also ohne Industriebeteiligung.
Die machen dort Concurrent Design Aktivitäten.
Wir haben aber Phase Null auch hier bei anderen Missionen schon oft gemacht.
Und das ist meistens so, dass man da noch nicht mit vielen Partnern zusammenarbeitet,
am besten macht man es als Firma alleine, weil zu viele Interfaces und Schnittstellen
führen zu Komplikationen.
Man muss da ziemlich schnell und interaktiv miteinander arbeiten.
Da ist gerade so ein Concurrent Engineering Approach eigentlich super.
Wir haben hier zum Beispiel diese CEFO, die Concurrent Engineering Facility.
Das ist ein Raum mit vielen Workstations, wo man gemeinsam sitzt und iterativ arbeitet.
Also die Idee ist, von jeder Disziplin sitzt dort jemand, ein Strukturingenieur,
eine Antriebsingenieurin, Thermalingenieurin und Missionsanalyst und so weiter.
Die sitzen alle in diesem Raum zusammen Und man kann ganz schnell das Design
zusammenbauen, sprich,
da wird was schwerer in der Masse, dann geht das direkt rüber zum Antrieb,
dann wird das Delta V angepasst, dann stellt sich heraus, wir brauchen größere
Tanks, das geht dann an die Akkommodation.
Also Delta V ist dann, wie viel Beschleunigung braucht das Fahrzeug?
Ja genau. Und dann merkt man, okay, wir brauchen größere Tanks oder größere
Thruster, dann geht das an die Akkommodation, dann wird das in dem Satellitendesign
eingebaut, jetzt muss die die Struktur wieder nachjustieren und so weiter.
Das sind solche Kreisläufe, die sonst Wochen dauern können, weil dann kriegt
wieder jemand eine E -Mail, dann muss er das bearbeiten, updaten,
schickt wieder eine E -Mail.
Und wenn man das in diesem CFO -Approach macht, dann sitzen alle gemeinsam in
diesem Raum und machen das, was sonst ewig dauern würde, weil man eben immer
diese langen Lead -Zeiten hat, wo man dann wartet, dass jemand irgendeine Aktion
macht. Alles innerhalb von ein paar Tagen.
Wie viele Leute halten sich dann da in diesem Raum auf? Also wie viele Wissenschaftler,
die kommen da an und wollen was und wie viele von euch?
Also das sind meistens erst mal nur Ingenieure. Wir haben selten,
dass wir die Wissenschaftler direkt im Raum haben. Manchmal binden wir die mit
ein, wenn es wirklich darum geht.
Da ist noch ganz viel offen, aber sonst sagen wir einfach, das ist der Input von denen.
Die briefen uns, die geben uns ihre Anforderungen und dann sitzen da nur Ingenieure
und das sind so fünf bis zehn Personen.
Unter anderem ist ja auch, glaube ich, das LISA -Projekt bei euch durchgegangen
oder geht noch sozusagen gerade durch?
Genau, also LISA läuft ja schon ewig und wir waren mal zu einem Zeitpunkt auch… Also LISA,
kurze Erklärung, ist ja Gravitationswellenastronomie im All,
also das, was derzeit nur auf der Erde gemacht wird mit drei großen oder weit
voneinander, nicht großen, aber weit voneinander entfernten Satelliten,
die ja so einen riesen Dreieck quasi mit Laser aufspannen.
Millionen von Kilometern.
Millionen von Kilometern voneinander entfernt sind und dann halt entsprechende
Streckungen im Raum messen sollen und ich kann mir vorstellen,
wenn man jetzt mit so einem Projekt ankommt, ich meine das ist ja auch so ein Ding,
das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Fernsehsatellit oder so, was schon tausendmal
irgendwie gebaut wurde und wo man auf Dinge zurückschauen kann und sagen,
ja okay, letztes Mal haben wir das so gemacht,
hat auch im Wesentlichen funktioniert, aber hier würden wir gerne noch ein bisschen
dran drehen, dann kriegt man das wahrscheinlich so im Nachmittag irgendwie weg.
Aber wenn jetzt sowas auf dem Tisch liegt, wo ja im Prinzip,
gut es gab jetzt diese Lisa, wie hieß sie?
Passfinder Mission. Genau, wo das ja im Prinzip einmal ausprobiert wurde.
Also da hat man jetzt sozusagen zumindest schon mal so dieses,
ja wir wissen das funktioniert auch, trotz alledem, den Moment wo sich die Größenordnungen
auch ändern, dann hat das ja ganz neue Anforderungen.
Warst du damit dabei oder weißt du wie das wohl gelaufen sein könnte oder kannst
du vielleicht mal so ein bisschen versuchen darauf zu projizieren?
Also Lisa ist eine Mission, die ist schon ganz, ganz lange in der Mache.
Und da hat sich auch schon ganz, ganz viel einfach umgeändert und gewandelt.
Also wir waren auch mal gar nicht in Lisa involviert und jetzt sind wir ganz
doll involviert, auch weil die Mission selber schon so viele Wandlungen durchgemacht hat.
Und jetzt kommen wir in die heiße Phase, denn wir erwarten jetzt,
dass demnächst das große ITT rauskommt, also das große Angebot geschrieben wird
für das tatsächliche Bauen von LISA.
Und genau, LISA ist eine wahnsinnig spannende, coole Mission,
weil es eben darum geht – das kann man sich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen
– aber mit diesen Satelliten in so einem riesigen Abstand zu fliegen und dann
aber auch hochgenau den Abstand zueinander zu messen mit diesen schwebenden Massen,
um äußere Störungen ausschließen zu können.
Die Goldwürfel, die da frei fliegen in den Satelliten selber drin.
Ja, also das ist richtig cool, aber auch extrem und ganz, ganz hoch anspruchsvoll.
Und darum hat das so lange gedauert. Darum gab es so, so lange,
so viele Vorstudien, weil es ganz viele Effekte gibt, wenn man dann ins Detail guckt.
Jedes Mal, wenn man denkt, jetzt machen wir eine Detaillierung mehr,
kommt, wir müssen noch viel genauer anschauen.
Und die allerwenigsten Missionen haben ja überhaupt diesen Luxus erstmal die
Technik in einer Mini -Version zu testen bevor man es los schickt.
Also das Allermeiste was ja im All landet sind Prototypen.
So und in dem Fall gab es zumindest schon mal eine Vorstufe davon.
Aber es zeigt auch wie anspruchsvoll das ist, weil das wirklich ungewöhnlich
ist, dass man so etwas macht.
Und ja und da wird es jetzt, da kommen wir jetzt demnächst hin,
dass wir da wirklich jetzt Angebote schreiben und dass es tatsächlich realisiert
wird. nach langer, langer, jahrzehntelanger Vorarbeit. Das ist aber ungewöhnlich.
Also LISA ist eine L -Class Mission, also eine Large -Class Mission.
Die letzte, die erste L, L1, ist JUICE. Das ist der JUICE, Jupiter,
Ice, Sea, Moon Explorer, der ist ja vor kurzem gelauncht.
LISA wird jetzt die zweite L -Class Mission und dann danach kommt vermutlich
das Röntgen -Observatorium Athena.
Und diese Missionen sind berüchtigt dafür, dass sie lange, lange Entwicklungszeiten
haben, dass sie auch sehr teuer sind, aber weil sie eben auch wirklich so am
Rande von dem sind, was man machen kann. Also wirklich Pioniermissionen.
Aber man kann sie jetzt nicht so gut als Beispiel verwenden,
weil sie eben so extrem… Okay, ich sehe, ich habe mich da ein bisschen verfangen.
Nenn doch mal ein Beispiel, in dem du vielleicht auch selber dabei warst.
Dass wir uns einfach mal diese Phase Null noch mal genauer vorstellen können.
Genau. Wir können vielleicht einfach nochmal über Comet Interceptor sprechen.
Das ist zwar mit diesen Phasen ein bisschen anders gelaufen,
aber das war sehr, sehr schnell und das war auch, finde ich, extrem spannend.
Also ist eine Mission, die wir hier noch nicht beleuchtet haben,
kann man vielleicht mal kurz sagen.
Also Comet Interceptor ist so die Idee, dass man gerne mal einen Kometen einfangen
möchte, der noch nicht schon fünfmal da war, sondern der mehr oder weniger das
erste Mal ins Sonnensystem eintritt und sich dann eben der Sonne nähert.
Sprich, bevor er das erste Mal angeschmolzen wird, dass man die Möglichkeit
hat Proben zu entnehmen,
als das Ding noch so richtig alt ist und das Problem ist in dem Moment,
wo man so einen entdeckt, dann baut manchmal mal eben eine Rakete und startet
die und ist rechtzeitig da.
Das heißt man muss im Prinzip schon im All sein und das ist glaube ich hier
die Idee, dass man irgendwie am Lagrange -Punkt L2 rumgammelt und wartet bis
was kommt. Ist natürlich auch gewagt.
Ja, also es ist sehr, sehr cool. Man ist eine Art Mitfahrer.
Ein Rideshare machen wir zusammen mit Ariel, dem Weltraumteleskop.
Und dann fliegen wir zum Lagrange -Zweipunkt und dort warten wir dann.
Und dann das Ganze basiert darauf, dass man geguckt hat, was gab es in der Vergangenheit
für Objekte und welche davon kann man mit welchem Delta -V, also mit welcher Antriebs -…,
Fähigkeit erreichen. Und das sollte so ausgelegt sein, dass man möglichst innerhalb
von der Betriebsdauer, ich glaube das sind fünf Jahre, möglichst viele mögliche
Objekte erreichen kann.
Und dann gibt es noch so ein paar Backups, das sind einfach Asteroiden,
wo man hinfliegen könnte, wenn man eben, wenn nichts kommt.
Aber es kann natürlich auch sein, dass wir richtig viel Glück haben und es kommt
so was Verrücktes wie dieser Omoamor, kannst du dich nicht daran erinnern?
Diese lange, schreckte… Genau, wo man halt einfach war so, was ist das?
Alle gleich wieder so, Raumschiff.
Raumschiff, aber das war ja wohl ein extrasolares Objekt, also eines,
was sogar den Ursprung noch nicht mal aus unserem Sonnensystem haben könnte.
Also man weiß einfach nicht, was kommt, das ist super spannend.
Aber irgendwas ist ja immer im All.
Irgendwas gibt es immer, genau. Und im Notfall gibt es eben auch einfach interessante Asteroiden.
Aber wenn es einen Kometen gibt, dann ist es ja so,
der Komet kommt von weit außerhalb Und des inneren Sonnensystems kommt er in
das Innere und wird dann von der Sonne angeschmolzen und beginnt dann dieses
Koma zu entwickeln, das ist dieser Schweif.
Meistens lösen die sich, das ist zumindest die Theorie, dass sie sich aus dieser
Ortschenwolke lösen durch irgendeine Schwankung.
Irgendwas fliegt vorbei, bringt so ein Stück Steinchen aus dem Tritt und dann
geht's ab die wilde Fahrt Richtung Sonnensystemzentrum.
Ganz genau. Und dann kommen sie her und je näher sie an die Sonne kommen,
desto mehr fängt an, sich diese Struktur dieses Kometen zu ändern.
Das Eis, was da drin ist, schmilzt auf.
Es sprüht Partikel und Wasserflocken und so weiter.
Alles wird rausgestoßen. Das ist dieser Kometenschweif.
Und den nimmt auch das Koma. Und dann würden wir mit unserem mit einem Dezeptor
kommen und fliegen voll durch dieses Koma durch.
Das heißt, wir mussten erst mal schauen, wie kann man sich davor schützen.
Da muss man Schilde mitnehmen.
Und die Geschwindigkeiten der Partikel, auf die wir da stoßen,
sind viel, viel schneller als alles, was wir aus dem Erdorbit kennen.
Da weiß man ja, man muss sich manchmal beschützen gegen zum Beispiel Schrottwolken oder sowas.
Aber da haben wir so relative Geschwindigkeiten von 14 Kilometer pro Sekunde
oder sowas. Und hier bei dem Koma geht es um 70, also gleich mal einen Faktor 5 höher.
Und das war zum Beispiel ein großer Punkt, den wir uns anschauen mussten.
Aber tendenziell war die Idee, wir machen das Ganze möglichst günstig,
weil es ist ja ein Mitflieger und es ist auch eine sogenannte F -Class Mission,
also eine Fast -Class Mission.
Es soll schnell entwickelt werden, es soll möglichst günstig sein.
Und um das zu realisieren, haben wir unsere HERA -Plattform genommen.
HERA ist eine Mission, die kommt nicht aus dem Science -Bereich,
ist aber ein bisschen wie eine Wissenschaftsmission, die kommt aus dem Space
-Safety -Bereich und das ist die Mission, die zu dem Asteroiden Didymos fliegt.
Didymos ist ein Asteroid, der hat einen kleinen Trabanten, also der hat einen
kleinen Mond, den man nennt man auch Didymoon, aber der heißt eigentlich anders,
ich kenne ihn aber nur unter Didymoon.
Also Didymos und der kleine Didymoon und NASA hat eine Mission gemacht,
die hieß DART und DART ist in Didymoon eingeschlagen und hat dadurch wahrscheinlich
die Trajektorie von Didymoon um Didymos verändert.
Das ist ein Beispiel oder eine Demonstrator -Mission für die bewusste Veränderung
der Trajektorie von solchen Objekten gewesen zur Asteroidenabwehr.
DIMORPHOS heißt er.
DIMORPHOS, so heißt er, genau.
DIMORPHOS und DIMORPHOS.
Okay. DIMORPHOS ist sein offizieller Name.
Und HERA soll jetzt dahin fliegen, um diesen Krater zu untersuchen,
den DART -Krater zu untersuchen.
Also ganz spannend, total coole Mission, die läuft hier auch bei OHB,
die wird hier gerade gebaut und unsere Idee war, wir nehmen,
was wir von Hera haben, weil die Missionen sich sehr ähneln und sagen,
das ist unser Startpunkt.
Und hier fangen wir jetzt an, möglichst wenig zu ändern, um die Mission für
Comet Interceptor erfüllen zu können.
Denn dann kann man das Ganze relativ günstig realisieren, weil man ja vieles
schon hat und nicht nochmal neu erfinden muss.
Dort passt es zu dem fast und günstig sozusagen.
Ganz genau.
Also Phase 0, hier ging dann also die Initiative von der ESA aus,
das war dann sozusagen der Erstkontakt.
Also da ruft hier jemand bei dir an und sagt so, hör mal.
Neues Projekt, lasst mal treffen.
Phase 0 hat ISA selber gemacht, intern. Und dann haben sie,
als sie damit durch waren und gesagt haben, das passt, das kriegen wir ungefähr
hin mit dem Budget nach unseren ersten Abschätzungen, da haben sie dann dieses
ITT veröffentlicht, das heißt Invitation to Tender.
Und das bedeutet für uns, wir schreiben ein Angebot.
Und da haben sich dann eben verschiedenste Konsortien zusammengetan,
unter anderem wir mit unseren Freunden und Schwestern aus Italien,
ORB Italia. Und haben auf dieses ITT ein Angebot geschrieben.
Jetzt ist es so, dass wir im Wissenschaftsbereich bei der ESA,
ja nicht nur, es geht nicht nur darum, die beste Wissenschaft zu machen,
sondern es geht auch darum, den geografischen Return zu erfüllen.
Das ist ja bei ESA generell immer ein Fall, das habt ihr bestimmt auch schon mal besprochen.
Geografischer Return?
Also die verschiedenen Beitrittsländer der ESA zahlen ihr Geld.
Und im Wissenschaftsbereich ist das ganz besonders interessant,
denn jedes Land muss beim Wissenschaftsbereich teilnehmen.
Also man kann nicht für eine bestimmte Mission ein Abonnement abschließen und
da sagen, okay, hier, ich tue mein Geld in diese Mission.
Sondern jeder muss einen gleichmäßigen Beitrag, der ans GDP,
also an das Bruttoinlandsprodukt gekoppelt ist, beitragen zum Wissenschaftsprogramm.
Und gleichzeitig hat ESA aber die Verpflichtung, dafür zu sorgen,
dass das Geld möglichst gerecht wieder zurückfließt in die Länder.
Also genau nach dem, was man beigetragen hat, das fließt auch wieder zurück.
Und da war eben bei, jetzt bei Comet Interceptor, war es so,
dass wir aus Deutschland gar nicht so einen riesigen Anteil haben konnten an der Mission.
Und darum haben wir dann gesagt, okay, Hera ist trotzdem super geeignet,
aber wir machen das zusammen mit unseren Freunden aus Italien.
Und wir helfen denen dabei, unsere Heritage weiter zu nutzen und sind dann zusammen
mit Italien reingegangen und haben das trotzdem geschafft, HERA dafür fertig
zu machen. Nur, dass das jetzt eben in Italien läuft.
Okay, also man hat quasi eine Plattform wieder neu genutzt, weil die eben auch
für diese Anforderungen geeignet ist, weil es ja im Prinzip genau das Gleiche ist.
Man jagt den Asteroiden hinterher oder den Kometen oder was auch immer es ist.
Genau, also dann wurde das Angebot geschrieben, wie gesagt ITT kam von ESO und
dann kam eben als erstes diese Phase A und in der Phase A macht man Trade -Offs,
das heißt wir sind ganz von Anfang an da hingegangen und haben gesagt, okay,
wir versuchen möglichst viel von HERA zu nutzen, da wo es Sinn macht,
aber wo macht es keinen Sinn und wir haben diese ganzen Punkte versucht rauszufinden.
Wo unterscheidet sich diese Mission Comet Interceptor von der Mission HERA und
ein Punkt habe ich gerade angesprochen, ist dieses Dust Shield,
was man braucht, weil man eben durchs Koma fliegt. Aber es gibt auch noch andere.
Zum Beispiel waren die Anforderungen an das Antriebssystem andere und so.
Und wir haben halt überall aufgestellt, was sind die größten Unterschiede und
was sind unsere Optionen.
Zum Beispiel bei dem Antriebssystem haben wir dann gesagt, okay,
wir können wieder das Antriebssystem von HERA wiederverwenden oder wir könnten
ein anderes benutzen, zum dieses oder dieses und haben dann die Missionsoptionen
durchgerechnet und zwar versucht möglichst abzuschätzen,
was hat das für einen Impact auf die Masse, was hat das für einen Impact auf
die Komplexität, auf die Risiken,
auf die Kosten und dann in jedem dieser Trade -Off -Punkte jeweils die beste
Option auszuwählen und dann am Ende der Phase A haben wir unser Missionskonzept
dann konsolidiert und damit haben wir alle Trade -Offs geschlossen und wissen
mit diesem Konzept gehen wir jetzt in die nächste Stufe, nämlich in die Ausarbeitung der Details.
Heißt das, dass jetzt beim Comet Interceptor auch euer Concurrent Engineering
Facility zum Einsatz gekommen ist?
Ja, tatsächlich. Also im Angebot haben wir das gemacht.
Da muss man ja innerhalb von ein paar Wochen dann eben sein Angebot zusammen
machen und da haben wir dann, finden wir immer, dass es ein super nützliches
Tool ist, diese Concurrent Engineering Facility zu nutzen.
Wir nutzen sie auch manchmal während der Studien, aber vor allem bei Angeboten
ist es extrem hilfreich.
Kannst du das vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen beschreiben, wie das dann konkret abläuft?
Also wir hatten ja schon die Situation, alle sitzen jetzt irgendwie in einem
Raum und ihr habt dann sozusagen spezialisierte Software, um da quasi parallel
an so einem Plan zu arbeiten. Kann man sich das so vorstellen?
Ja, es ist mehr eine Arbeitsweise, aber es gibt auch Software.
Aber es geht vor allem darum, wir haben einen, der leitet diese Facility und
der bereitet sich darauf vor und der moderiert das Ganze und hat vorher schon
alles zusammengetragen, was man dafür braucht.
Also die Missionsanforderungen und hat so eine Art Zeitplan entwickelt und dann
geht man wirklich, das ist wie so ein Workshop, kann man sagen.
Und die Teilnehmer wissen auch,
was sie erwartet und dann benutzen wir bestimmte Software -Tools auch.
Also wir benutzen zum Beispiel ein Tool, mit dem man Actions vergeben kann und
synchron an Dokumenten und so arbeiten kann, dass man da gleichzeitig an bestimmte
Sachen zugreifen kann und so.
Aber der Kern davon ist wirklich dieses, man kommt zusammen,
man hat einen festen Zeitplan und in diesem Zeitplan macht man mehrere ganz
schnelle Iterationen des Designs.
Aber die Software ist dann so in -house entwickelt oder sind das einfach auch
Werkzeuge der Luft - und Raumfahrtindustrie, die zum Einsatz kommen?
Also es werden erstmal Werkzeuge, also erstmal werden die Tools,
die darin verwendet werden, sind nicht nur für die CEFO.
Die meisten sind halt Sachen, die man sowieso auch verwendet.
Zum Beispiel für Missionsanalyse wird einfach das normale Missionsanalyse -Tool verwendet.
Es gibt aber auch spezielle CEFO -Software, aber da weiß ich nicht genau,
welche das ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass die speziell für OHB entwickelt ist.
Also es ist sozusagen ein Modus in dem man sich dann befindet und da geht es
dann schnell und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das eine Menge Spaß macht,
dann immer sozusagen mit den anderen Experten rum zu optimieren,
weil das ist halt immer so das Problem.
Mit Optimierung heißt, man versucht halt einen optimalen Zustand zu erreichen
und jeder möchte gerne so, wäre aber cool, wenn ich jetzt hier noch das ein
bisschen größer baue und dann kommen irgendwie die Thermiker und sagen, wird viel zu heiß.
Ja, müssen wir so machen und dann sagen, ja nee, da kriegen wir aber den Antrieb
nicht für gebaut, dann ist das
zu schwer, dann kriegen wir das nicht gelauncht und nicht all so Sachen.
Und am Ende steht irgendjemand und sagt, ja habt euch jetzt schön ausgedacht,
aber es ist viel zu teuer.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, ich habe ein paar Mal an solchen Sessions teilgenommen
und ich fand es jedes Mal einfach faszinierend, wie viel man hinkriegt am Ende.
Hat man wirklich Seitenweise, Konzepte, Bilder, Analyseergebnisse und so weiter.
Es ist richtig komplett nach einer Woche Arbeit.
Man ist auch durch dann, also es ist anstrengend, einfach weil man die ganze Zeit konzentriert ist.
Das Gehirn läuft die ganze Zeit auf Hochtouren von allen zusammen,
aber am Ende sind eigentlich immer alle total glücklich und stolz,
was man da alles zustande bekommen hat.
Und da lernt man dann wahrscheinlich auch eine Menge über die anderen Bedürfnisse.
Weil das ja oft so ein bisschen das Problem ist, wenn so Abteilungen alle so
für sich arbeiten und am Ende will man alles zusammenstecken und stellt fest
so, wir hätten uns vielleicht mal auf einen einheitlichen Stecker einigen sollen,
umso früher man sowas macht.
Das ist ja eine Metapher, die kann man ja auch auf alle anderen Arbeitssituationen
ein bisschen übertreiben.
Ich glaube jeder, der in einem Unternehmen mit anderen Leuten zusammenarbeiten
muss, kann ganz gut nachfühlen, was das dann für Momente sind.
Absolut.
Okay, ich wollte noch ein bisschen mal auf diese Phasen, aber die sind vielleicht gar nicht so…,
Klar definiert immer, aber wir bewegen uns jetzt hier bei dem Combat Interceptor
im Prinzip jetzt in dieser Machbarkeitsstudie.
Das heißt, das ist dann schon etwas, wofür OHB dann auch offiziell beauftragt
wird, wo schon Geld fließt, wo die ESA sozusagen investiert und sagt,
okay, jetzt müsste mal konkreter werden, aber da redet man halt nicht mehr mit
den Wissenschaftlern, sondern eben schon mit Leuten von der ESA.
Ja, richtig, genau. Also ab dem Punkt reden wir nicht mehr mit den Wissenschaftlern,
ESA redet noch mit den Wissenschaftlern.
Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt ist es ja so, dass während dieser Machbarkeitsstudie,
dass es eigentlich immer mindestens zwei parallele Studien gibt.
Also man befindet sich in einer Wettbewerbssituation und da wäre es nicht fair,
wenn dann ein Konsortium mit den Wissenschaftlern direkt redet.
Darum übernimmt ESA diese ganze Kommunikation.
Aber die sind weiterhin eingebunden, gerade wenn es darum geht,
dass zum Beispiel von uns rausgefunden wird. Wir können bestimmte Anforderungen
nicht so erfüllen oder wir müssen uns entscheiden dies oder das,
dann werden die Wissenschaftler wieder konsultiert, damit sie auch ihren Senf
dazugeben können, ob das akzeptabel ist.
Welcher Teil von ESA spricht dann mit euch? Ist das die Raumfahrtagentur oder
sind das dann auch unterschiedliche Bereiche?
Also ESA hat ja mehrere Direktorate und jetzt für die Wissenschaftsmission ist
es das Direktorat Science und da gibt es dann immer einen Technical Officer,
der für ein bestimmtes Projekt zuständig ist und das ist dann die Hauptansprechperson für diese Projekte.
Aber wenn wir in der Studie sind, dann ist es oft so, und das finde ich auch immer am,
allereffektivsten, dass wir nicht nur mit dem Technical Officer sprechen,
sondern dass wir die ganzen Experten von ESA -Seite, da gibt es dann halt Thermalexperten,
Strukturexperten und so weiter,
direkt mit unserem Thermalexperten, unserem Strukturexperten in direkten Austausch bringen.
Die haben dann die E -Mail -Adressen und Telefonnummern voneinander und können
direkt miteinander Sachen besprechen.
Und das ist eine viel bessere Art und Weise zu arbeiten. Und dann können Probleme
auch ganz schnell auf dem niedrigsten Level gelöst werden, ohne dass das immer
gleich über mehrere Personen und Hörensagen und stille Post weitergetragen werden muss.
Wo diese Personen sind, das ändert sich dann auch von Mission zu Mission.
Es gibt jetzt nicht so einen Korpus der ESA, der primär zu euch spricht,
sondern je nach Mission sind das Leute mal beim ESTEC, mal hier,
mal in der Agentur, mal bei der Mission oder wo sind die meistens vertreten?
Also es ist meistens ASTEC mit denen wir reden. Es sei denn es geht um Operationssachen,
das ist dann häufig ESOC in Darmstadt.
Genau, also ASTEC in den Niederlanden, da wo halt die Satelliten letzten Endes
dann auch getestet und auf die Reise geschickt werden, die sind sehr viel näher dran am Bau.
Ja, an der Industrie.
Genau, und Launch ist natürlich dann in Darmstadt. Die wollen natürlich auch mitreden.
Und der Satellitenbetrieb allgemein ist dann in Darmstadt. Wir haben auch manchmal
Missionen, die sind sehr betriebsorientiert.
Da haben wir dann auch ganz viel direkt mit denen zu tun.
Aber genau, ich würde sagen 90 Prozent unserer Kontakte sind dann mit ESTEC.
Und was das Launchfahrzeug selber betrifft, die italienische Mission,
ist das dann eine Vega Mission oder mit welcher Rakete geht das dann hoch?
Das Comet Interceptor ist ein Shared Launch, die fliegen zusammen mit Ariel
auf einer Ariane, glaube ich.
Okay, dachte ich mir schon fast. Das ist wahrscheinlich was Größeres,
was weiter weg muss. Da braucht man eine Menge Power.
Das könnte dann eine Ariane 6 Mission werden.
Ich meine so war es.
Ja, weil die Ariane 5 ist ja jetzt eigentlich raus.
Genau, die gibt es nicht mehr. So ist es. Und ansonsten ist es sowieso meistens,
dass es europäische Launch -Vehikel sind, aber es hängt mal von Mission zu Mission ab.
Also wir haben jetzt auch häufiger mal Situationen, wo wir auch mal gucken,
was gibt es so an neuen möglichen Launchern auf dem Markt.
Gerade wenn es um kleine Missionen geht, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt im Science
-Bereich so, aber in anderen, dass man halt schon mal schaut,
welche zukünftigen Launch -Provider gibt es denn.
Weil wir haben ja viele Entwicklungen in Europa gerade von kleinen Launchern.
Und es kann immer mal was dazwischen kommen, das hatten wir hier in der letzten
Sendung, als wir über Euclid gesprochen haben.
Da sollte es ja eigentlich auch schon mit der Ariane 6, beziehungsweise in Schuh
ursprünglich, mit der Sojus werden und Ariane 6 stand dann nicht zur Verfügung,
sodass dann auf die Falcon umgewechselt wird. Das ist natürlich dann immer diese
Unvorhersehbarkeit von allen möglichen Rahmenbedingungen.
Man weiß ja nicht, was einem nächstes Wochenende schon wieder um die Ohren fliegt.
Ein Beruf, wo man auf Veränderungen vorbereitet sein muss.
Ja und das ist total dramatisch eigentlich, weil wir ja unsere ganzen Analysen
und auch unsere Tests auf eine bestimmte Launcher -Umgebung anpassen.
Also wir gucken ja, was sind die Schocklasten, die wir erwarten in dem Launch
-Vehikel und Und wenn das dann geändert wird, das hat richtig große Konsequenzen.
Das ist nicht so einfach wie, ach, dann nehme ich halt einen anderen Bus oder
so, sondern das ist wirklich, das kann das ganze Design nochmal über den Haufen
werfen und man muss nochmal nachbessern.
Weil einfach mehr gerüttelt wird und andere Frequenzen oder so angeregt werden.
Das ist ganz.
Es hat wirklich sehr viele Auswirkungen und das ist für uns auch eine blöde
Situation gerade, muss man sagen.
Was ist dann letztlich der Umfang einer Machbarkeitsstudie? Weil eine Machbarkeitsstudie
klingt für mich jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht auch so ein bisschen so,
ja könnte man, kann man mal machen irgendwie, so klingt jetzt nicht so genau.
Aber ich schätze mal, da sind schon eine ganze Menge Parameter ziemlich auf
kleinste Nuancen runtergedreht worden.
Ja, also wenn wir jetzt von der Phase A sprechen, dann machen wir da eben diese
Missionskonzepte, die wir gegeneinander abwägen und dann eins auswählen.
Das arbeiten wir dann so weit aus, dass man am Ende der Phase A die Risiken
abschätzen kann, den Technologieentwicklungen, die nötig sind.
Also wir gucken uns die verschiedenen Komponenten des Atleten an und schauen,
was für ein TAL haben die, also Technology Readiness Level. Sind die schon mal geflogen?
Muss man die noch entwickeln? Muss man da noch wirklich viel Geld reinstecken?
Und was ist der Schedule? Wie lange dauert das bis es so weit ist,
dass man das einsetzen kann?
Was ist generell der Schedule für die Entwicklung dieses Satelliten?
Also wie lange würde das jetzt dauern, wenn wir jetzt das okay bekämen,
bis wir den launchen könnten?
Weil manchmal hat man ja auch Komponenten drin, die brauchen einfach ihre Zeit, bis sie fertig sind.
Dann gucken wir an die Kosten, das ist ganz wichtig, dass man die Kosten schon
mal einmal abschätzen kann, damit man auch identifizieren kann,
was sind die Kostentreiber und ist das überhaupt innerhalb des Budgets machbar.
Und dann Risiken hatte ich schon angesprochen, aber auch hier ist es wichtig,
dass man guckt, welche größten Risiken gibt es und wie kann man die irgendwie mitigieren.
Was können wir jetzt schon machen, um bestimmte Risiken zu verringern?
Wenn wir zum Beispiel sehen, es gibt einen ganz wichtigen Teil in dem Satelliten
Und der wird nur von einer Quelle, kann man den nur beziehen.
Dann muss man ganz sicher sein, dass man den von der Quelle auch bekommen kann.
Oder alternativ gucken, dass man eine zweite Quelle irgendwo findet.
Oder sicher gehen, dass das dann auch wirklich da verfügbar ist.
Weil das will man natürlich nicht, dass der Teil dann plötzlich nicht mehr zu
nutzen ist. Also das ist so ein Beispiel.
Also ein Wirtschaftsembargo einem dazwischengekommen ist und es gibt keine Check -ins -Force, ne?
Ja, oder was weiß ich, ein ganzes Warenhaus ist abgebrannt oder so.
Man weiß es ja nicht. Es können ja die verrücktesten Sachen passieren und sind auch schon passiert.
Das sind so Punkte, die man eben in dieser Studie macht, dass man wirklich sich
alles anguckt und sagt, okay, Machbarkeit bezieht halt auch sowas mit ein.
Und eben natürlich das Satellitendesign. Wie groß ist der? Wie sieht der aus?
Wie schwer ist der? Kann der gelaunched werden? Wie viel Power braucht der?
Was für Komponenten hat der alles? Und am Ende hast du einen Product Tree,
da sind die verschiedenen Komponenten gelistet, einen Funktionsbaum,
das sind die Funktionen, die der Satellit ausführen soll,
runtergebrochen auf ganz viele kleine Teilfunktionen.
Und man hat die Anforderungen des Satelliten, also die von der Nutzerseite kommen,
auf eine Satellitenspezifikation umgeschrieben.
Und das ist so das Ende von der Phase A ungefähr.
Wie sieht dieses Endprodukt dieser Phase denn konkret aus?
Ist das einfach nur ein 300 Seiten PDF, wo alles schön ausgeschrieben dasteht?
Oder erhält die ESA oder wer auch immer gerade jetzt Kunde ist,
da ein wohl definiertes parametrisierbares Datenmodell,
wo man irgendwie am Computer rumschrauben kann und sich sozusagen in all seinen
potenziellen Ausprägungen immer wieder neu berechnen lassen kann?
Ja, das ist total spannend. Also das ist tatsächlich eine super Frage,
weil das ändert sich gerade.
Traditionell kriegt ESA von uns vordefinierte Dokumente, die so beschrieben
sind in unseren Industrienormen.
Also es gibt so etwas wie ein Mission Definition Document zum Beispiel oder
verschiedene Analyse Reports.
Und die sind vorher im Vertrag aufgenommen, die werden geliefert und dann werden
die von uns bereitgestellt und gebaut. und eben bestimmte Modelle,
wie zum Beispiel ein CAD -Modell und ein Finite -Element -Modell.
Aber was sich gerade ändert in der Industrie, ist, dass wir sogenanntes MBSE
implementieren, also Model Based System Engineering.
Und da ist das ähnlich wie das, was du gerade beschrieben hast,
dass man wirklich einen virtuellen Satelliten hat,
wo die Anforderungen des Kunden direkt mit den Spezifikationen des Atleten verknüpft
sind und nicht mehr nur über Dokumente als Schnittstellen verlaufen,
sondern eben durch ein richtiges Computermodell.
Das heißt, das ist noch nicht so, aber das ist alte Portals.
Das ist bei manchen Missionen so. Also manche Missionen machen das jetzt schon
so und andere ältere Missionen, die schon lange laufen, bei denen ist es quasi
nicht implementiert worden und wird vermutlich auch nicht mehr implementiert.
Das ist der Umbruch, der jetzt gerade so stattfindet.
Okay, also wir befinden uns da sozusagen gerade in so einer neuen Digitalisierungsphase,
weil es macht ja eigentlich auch für alle Beteiligten total Sinn,
nicht immer wieder alles sich neu anlesen zu müssen und dann so,
was steht denn da jetzt nochmal genau für eine Zahl,
so dass man das halt einfach auch in der Simulation vielleicht sofort zum Einsatz
bringen kann, was ja dann auch, sagen wir mal Turnaround -Zeiten bei Änderungswünschen
oder Anforderungsänderungen dann kürzer machen wird.
Ganz genau. Das ist eben genau dieser Punkt, diese Anforderungsänderung.
Da ändert sich irgendwas im Input und wenn man das in einem old -fashioned way
macht, dann dauert es einfach ewig bis sich das durchgefressen hat auf alle
Level und manchmal gibt es auch einfach einen Punkt,
wo es dann übersehen wird und es findet sich dann gar nicht mehr wieder.
Also es hört dann einfach irgendwo auf und versickert und das ist eben das,
was man damit ausschließen kann.
Das ist ja auch eine echte Gefahr für so eine Mission. Wenn man irgendein Konstraint
nur in so einem Textdokument verbirgt und dann wird irgendwo was geändert,
was auf diesen Parametern eine Auswirkung hat und der überschreitet dann auf
einmal seine Grenzwerte und keiner merkt es, weil es halt nicht angeschaut wurde,
dann ist man ja schnell in deep trouble.
Ja, absolut. Genau, das ist sowieso das, was man immer hat. Bei uns jetzt in
der Vorentwicklung ist es noch nicht mal so dramatisch.
Wir legen so die Grundsteine dafür, dass das später funktioniert.
Aber wenn dann nachher der Satellit wirklich da ist, man hat schon angefangen,
bestimmte Sachen zu kaufen,
die Aufträge rausgegeben und dann merkt man, das passt hier aber nicht mehr,
dann hat man wirklich ein Riesenproblem, weil dann muss man vielleicht Sachen
nochmal neu kaufen Oder man muss ganz kostspielige Änderungen durchführen lassen
und das will man natürlich möglichst vermeiden.
Und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das gerade bei so was wie, ne, Beispiel Hera,
man möchte sozusagen eine alte Mission anpassen und sagen so,
da haben wir doch schon mal so eine Plattform,
guck mal, das Ding hat ja auch im Wesentlichen eigentlich das Gleiche gemacht,
bloß mit ein paar anderen Parametern, dann könnte man das natürlich auch sehr
viel einfacher aus der Schublade wieder hervorziehen und sagen so,
da gehen wir jetzt mal drauf.
Ja, total. Genau. Und auch noch mehr. Also es ist nicht nur,
dass man das Design und so weiter dann digitaler, man hat ja auch noch andere
Sachen, man hat ja bestimmte Komponenten zum Beispiel schon qualifiziert und
man hat die Testresultate davon, die man dann zur Verfügung hat.
Es gibt so viel, was im Moment noch, sagen wir mal in Anführungsstrichen,
lose rumflattert und dass man das alles besser verknüpft und so,
das ist ein Riesenbestreben.
Das ist auch sehr komplex und auch sehr, sehr, sehr viel Aufwand.
Erstmal aber einer, der sich auf jeden Fall auszahlt.
Und das ist genau so ein Umbruch, der gerade stattfindet.
So, wenn so eine Machbarkeitsstudie dann gemacht ist, dann kommt Phase B.
Was heißt das? Requirements, Consolidation?
Genau, also der Preliminary Requirements Review ist am Ende.
Und in der Phase B1 ist es so,
wir haben ja unsere Satellitenspezifikation, Das ist die Übersetzung der Anforderungen
des Nutzers an unseren Satelliten und was wir jetzt machen ist,
wir brechen das weiter runter von den Satellitenanforderungen an die Spezifikationen
an die Subsystemspezifikationen,
also eine Thermalsubsystemspezifikation, eine Struktursubsystemspezifikation und so weiter.
Da stehen dann, ich gebe mal ein ganz praktisches Beispiel.
Wie so ein Satellit wirklich gebaut ist?
Naja, das ist die Akkommodation. Die Struktur ist wirklich die Strukturelemente.
Also das, was den Satelliten zusammenhält, wo alles dran getackert ist.
Ich gebe mal ein Beispiel. Wir haben zum Beispiel vom Kunden eine Anforderung,
dass die Launchmasse die x Kilogramm nicht übertreten darf.
Und jetzt sagen wir, okay, es kann einfach der Satellit maximal x Kilogramm schwer sein.
Wenn man jetzt aber auf Subsystem -Ebene geht, dann muss ich sagen,
okay, das propulsion -Subsystem darf nicht schwerer als ein Fraction,
ein Bruchteil von X sein.
Und das ist so die klassische System -Engineering -Aufgabe auch.
Das heißt, wir nehmen die Top -Level -Anforderungen und wir brechen sie runter
auf die verschiedenen Teil -Anforderungen.
Ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist auch, das kommt jetzt aus dem Erdbeobachtungsbereich,
aber ich finde es immer ein schönes, ansprechendes Beispiel,
wir haben eine Anforderung, wir müssen wissen, unser Bild ist auf dem und dem
Bereich des Bodens aufgenommen.
Geolokalisierung nennt man das, geolocation. Dann können wir auf Satellitenebene
dann sagen, okay, wir müssen so und so genau wissen, wo wir uns im Orbit befinden.
Wir müssen so und so genau wissen, in welche Richtung wir gucken.
Und wir müssen auch noch so und so genau wissen, wie sich unser Instrument im
Verhältnis zu unserer Blickrichtung bewegt hat.
Also guckt das immer noch genau straight oder ist das leicht verrutscht?
Und das sind alles Winkel, die werden dann, oder auch im Sinne von Warp -Position,
das ist ja auch eine absolute Position,
und die werden dann wieder als Anforderung an die einzelnen Teile runtergebrochen
und weiterverteilt. Und das machen wir im System Engineering.
Und dann haben wir diese Spezifikation auf Subsystem -Ebene und die werden dann
weiter runtergebrochen auf Spezifikationen für einzelne Komponenten.
Und diese Komponentenspezifikationen, die können wir dann wiederum an eine Ausschreibung
beifügen und können dann verschiedene Hersteller von zum Beispiel einem Reaction
Wheel anschreiben und sagen,
wir brauchen ein Reaction Wheel, das kann Folgendes.
Also Reaction Wheel zur Positionierung des Satelliten.
Genau, Reaction Wheel ist so ein Standardbauteil im Satelliten.
Darin ist so ein drehendes Rad mit einer hohen Masse oder auf jeden Fall ein Schwungrad.
Genau und damit kann man sich ja dann, wenn man genug davon hat,
kann man sich drehen und wenn zu viele davon kaputt sind, dann taumelt der Satellit davon.
So ist es, genau.
Und dann war's das. Hubble hat so ein Problem. Noch geht's.
Ja, vielleicht nochmal auf diese Model -Based -System -Engineering -Zukunft zu schauen.
Das ist ja eigentlich etwas, was man sozusagen partnerübergreifend dann machen will.
Mehr oder weniger arbeiten dann alle auf dem idealerweise sozusagen mehr oder
weniger in Real -Time auf demselben Modell oder sind zumindest in der Lage,
so wie das auch in der Softwareentwicklung ist, mehr oder weniger alle an dem
gleichen Apparat zu arbeiten und jeder bringt seine Änderungen mit ein.
Aber in -house dürfte das ja dann sowieso schon der Standard sein,
dass man hier an einem digitalen Modell arbeitet.
Wie gesagt, die Laufzeit von solchen Projekten ist sehr lang.
Viele von den Projekten, an denen wir jetzt ganz konkret arbeiten,
sind schon vor Jahren entwickelt worden.
Die Phase A ist schon Jahre her und bei denen ist es nicht der Fall,
dass das MBSE von Anfang an dabei war. Und dann ist es dann irgendwann auch
so, dass das Projekt schon so komplex ist, dass es zu spät ist, das noch einzuführen.
Aber hier in der Vorentwicklung für die Projekte, die wir jetzt neu anfangen,
da ist es eigentlich standardmäßig dabei.
Genau, das meinte ich. Also das ist jetzt der Modus Operandi für die Zukunft.
Ja.
Okay.
Wie sah das jetzt bei diesem Combat Interceptor, um mal wieder ein konkretes
Beispiel aus der Tasche zu holen, für diese Phase B, also für das Mission,
also Phase A Machbarkeit.
Wir können uns vorstellen so und so läuft das. Hier habt ihr irgendwie unsere
Daten oder unser Modell oder zumindest unser...
5 Kilo schweres PDF, was ihr euch durchlesen könnt.
Steht drin, könnte man im Prinzip machen mit dem und dem Aufwand an Geld.
Das sagt es ja letzten Endes aus.
Und wenn dann eben der nächste Schritt kommt und dann diese B1 Phase losgeht
und wenn ich das richtig jetzt verstanden habe, heißt es ja noch nicht,
das wird auf jeden Fall stattfinden, sondern es ist vielleicht immer noch einer
von mehreren Contendern, dann ist das ja sozusagen auch wettbewerbsrelevant.
Was kommt denn dann noch hinzu?
Inwiefern wird denn diese Machbarkeitsstudie dann nennenswert noch konkretisiert
über den ursprünglichen Stand hinaus?
Also genau, also das, was ich gerade beschrieben hatte mit dem Runterbrechen
der Spezifikationen auf die Komponenten, das kommt in der Phase B1.
Dann machen wir die sogenannten Request for Information oder Request for Proposal,
dass wir an Komponentenhersteller uns wenden und denen unsere Spezifikationen
schicken, um von denen zu erfahren, wie sieht das aus, können die das erfüllen.
Also dadurch kriegen wir einfach viel, viel mehr Input nochmal in unser Modell,
wie über Risiken, über Kosten und so weiter.
Das ist also ganz großer Fokus ist jetzt darauf, ganz konkret, wie sieht das Ding aus.
Wer baut das?
Welche Komponenten sind dabei? Und auch die Kosten werden dadurch viel konkreter.
Und das ist diese ganze Vorbereitung, der Fokus ist jetzt ganz stark darauf, das zu implementieren.
In der Phase A ist der Fokus darauf, die Mission selber, wie könnte die aussehen?
Wie gesagt, Missionskonzept. Und dann in der Phase B1 ist der Fokus auf,
wie bereiten das jetzt vor, dafür, dass es implementiert werden kann.
Aber eben noch im Wettbewerb befindlich. Und das ist auch ganz besonders wichtig,
weil wenn eine Firma das machen würde, die weiß, wir haben das jetzt auf jeden Fall schon sicher,
dann fehlt so ein kleines bisschen auch der Anreiz, wirklich nochmal alles genau
anzuschauen, wo kann man noch was verbessern, wo kann man noch Kosten sparen oder so.
Ich denke, das ist schon sinnvoll, dass das meistens so gehandhabt wird.
Bei der Wissenschaftsmission ist
es jetzt schon sicher, dass diese Mission kommt, also so gut wie sicher.
Es gibt dann zwar noch diesen Mission Adoption Review meistens,
wo dann entschieden wird, tatsächlich kommt die Mission,
aber bei der Phase B1 ist die eigentlich nicht mehr in Konkurrenz zu anderen
Missionen, sondern nur noch in Konkurrenz zwischen zwei Industriekonsortien.
Okay, also man weiß, man will es machen, aber es ist noch nicht klar, wer es macht.
So ist es genau. Es kann halt passieren, dass die Mission dann doch noch gestoppt
wird, weil zum Beispiel doch die Risiken und Kosten sich als zu hoch erweisen
oder dass sie nochmal ganz signifikant redefiniert wird.
Aber in den meisten Fällen ist das nicht der Fall, sondern dann geht es halt einfach danach weiter.
Und nach der Phase B1, das ist jetzt, die ich gerade beschrieben habe,
kommt eigentlich das Angebot für die Implementierung.
Bei Comet Interceptor war es nicht so. Da hatten wir dann noch die Phase B2,
die weiterhin im Wettbewerb stattgefunden hat.
Was ich gerade auch noch vergessen habe zu erwähnen, sind die ganz detaillierten
Analysen, die in der Zeit durchgeführt werden.
Wir haben am Anfang in der Phase A die Analysen sind der Fokus Machbarkeit,
also wo haben wir Probleme mit den Schocklasten, wo haben wir Probleme thermal
und im zweiten Teil geht es darum,
die Umgebungswerte für die Komponenten zu definieren.
Das heißt, wir wissen jetzt schon, es müsste thermal und strukturell eigentlich
alles funktionieren, Aber die einzelnen Komponenten müssen wissen,
welche Schocks erfahre ich eigentlich?
Wie sieht meine Thermalumgebung aus? Und da gibt es ganz detaillierte Analysen,
die durchgeführt werden, um diese Werte bereitzustellen für die einzelnen Komponentenhersteller.
Viel von dem, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, bezieht sich ja im Wesentlichen auf, sagen wir mal,
Den Satelliten als solchen, so das Fahrzeug mit dem man irgendwie die Instrumente dann hinbringt.
Aber es ist ja immer so ein Zweispiel aus Transportfahrzeug auf der einen Seite
und der eigentlichen wissenschaftlichen Nutzlast selber.
Die werden ja dann oft auch von Universitäten gebaut. Da hat man ein tolles
neues Teleskop, irgendwelche Kameras, die irgendwas beobachten und auch das
sind ja immer dann quasi so bleeding edge Prototypen.
Man macht halt was, was man noch nicht gemacht hat. Das ist ja dann sozusagen
auch ein Teil, den ihr gar nicht so definieren könnt.
Im Science -Bereich ist das richtig, da ist es so, dass die Instrumente in aller
allermeisten Fällen Beistellungen sind von Mitgliedsstaaten der ESA oder manchmal auch sogar von anderen,
Raumfahrtagenturen von der NASA oder so oder von JAXA,
aber wo wir als Industrie über ESA nicht involviert sind, das heißt die sind
für uns, nennen wir sogenanntes CFI, Customer Furnished Item.
Und das heißt, wir bekommen einmal die Schnittstellenbeschreibung und wir wissen,
was ist wichtig für dieses Instrument. Manchmal ist das ja auch noch nicht fertig entwickelt.
Meistens ist es noch nicht fertig entwickelt. Das heißt, wir sind da auch in Iterationen mit denen.
Aber wir designen das nicht, sondern wir stellen sicher, dass das Raumfahrzeug
dieses Instrument sicher dorthin bringen kann, wo es eingesetzt wird und dann
dafür sorgen kann, dass der Einsatz auch funktioniert, dass die Daten weitergeleitet werden und so.
Es gibt aber Bereiche bei OHB, wo wir auch für das Instrument zuständig sind,
ganz besonders in der Erdbeobachtung ist das häufig der Fall.
Und da kommt das dann alles in die Hand, also das ganze Raumsegment ist dann
von der Industrie aufgebaut.
Andersrum. Die Industrie ist damit beauftragt.
Das heißt, es gibt ja auch schon einen nennenswerten wissenschaftlichen Teil.
Also es ist nicht nur so, dass OHB ausschließlich Ingenieure sind,
die irgendwie, ja, können wir euch bauen.
Wir wissen nicht, was das ist, aber wir bauen euch das.
Also wir wissen nicht, was mitfliegt sozusagen. Dem ist nicht so,
sondern es gibt ja auch einen Anteil an nennenswerten Wissenschaftlern,
die auch wirklich konkret Forschung betreiben und Entwicklungen vorantreiben
oder mehr so dazwischen sind, so ein bisschen umsetzen, was woanders erforscht wurde,
was so abgehangene Technologie ist.
So richtige Forscher würde ich sagen nicht, aber der Anspruch ist natürlich,
wir verstehen, was wir da machen, weil es für uns natürlich total wichtig ist,
zu verstehen, was wollen die Wissenschaftler bezwecken.
Denn wenn wir mit den Wissenschaftlern reden müssen und sagen,
das und das funktioniert nicht so, wie ihr euch das vorstellt,
dann müssen wir auch wissen, was bedeutet das für die.
Und wenn wir denen eine Alternative anbieten, dass das für die überhaupt sinnvoll
ist. Man muss irgendwie die gleiche Sprache sprechen.
Also schon echt wichtig, dass wir das verstehen.
Was wir hier nicht haben, ist Astrophysiker, die Astrophysik betreiben im Namen von UHB.
Wir haben aber Leute, die aus dem Bereich kommen und die das studiert haben
und die jetzt eben auf der anderen Seite sitzen und die sind für uns ganz wichtige
Kollegen, weil die eben diese Sprache sprechen von den Wissenschaftlern.
Und was wir hier machen, nennt sich auch Forschung und Entwicklung.
Wir forschen aber eben nicht an der Herkunft des Universums oder der Entstehung
des Universums oder der fundamentalen Physik, sondern wir forschen und entwickeln
neue Methoden, Raumbetrieb zu leisten, Raumfahrzeuge zu erstellen.
Wir entwickeln neue Technologien, die man einsetzen kann.
Also zum Beispiel auch Antriebstechnologien, Energiegewinnungssysteme,
würde mir sofort einfallen, auch noch als ganz wichtige Komponente, sowas.
Ja, also konkret haben wir jetzt bei OAB -Systemen nicht, aber was wir zum Beispiel
entwickeln, ist, wir entwickeln Design -for -Demise -Methoden.
Das sind Methoden, wie man Satelliten und auch Produkte, die man in Satelliten
verbauen kann, die dafür sorgen,
dass diese beim Wiedereintritt in die Erdatmosphäre komplett verglühen.
Das heißt, es ist nicht Wissenschaftsmission, also auch relevant für Wissenschaftsmissionen,
es ist für alle Missionen relevant und hat wieder was mit diesem Thema Weltraumschrott zu tun.
Genau. Kommen wir noch zu, jetzt würde mich noch mal interessieren,
was ja so ein bisschen das Environment hier anders macht als,
sagen wir mal typischerweise, wie ich ihn jetzt so bei der ESA oder bei den
sonstigen wissenschaftlichen Instituten,
Universitäten etc., wo ich schon überall war und die alle noch so Teil des ganzen
Weltraumzirkus ja sind.
Das ist ja hier, sagen wir mal so, die Wettbewerbsrealität ganz anders niederschlägt.
Man steht in Konkurrenz zu anderen Unternehmen und man hat es irgendwie aber
auch mit einem sehr überschaubaren Markt zu tun.
Es gibt ja jetzt auch nicht so viele Player, die in der Lage sind überhaupt
so einen Satelliten zu bauen. Den gibt es halt nicht im Supermarkt.
Wie beeinflusst das so deine Arbeit? Also spielt es eine Rolle?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich habe ja auch einen PhD gemacht,
ich habe auch mal im universitären Betrieb gearbeitet.
Und das Erste, was mir ganz klar geworden ist, als ich in die Industrie gewechselt
bin, ist, meine Zeit kostet Geld.
Das war vorher nicht so. Also das war in einer gewissen Hinsicht schon so,
aber ich habe es nie gemerkt.
Es war immer so, ich habe eine Frage und ich gehe der Frage nach,
bis ich eine Antwort habe. Und in der Industrie ist das nicht so,
weil man muss immer gucken, die Zeit, die ich jetzt einsetze,
um die und die Frage zu beantworten, ist es wert?
Weil ein Projekt ist mit einer bestimmten Anzahl von Stunden ausgestattet.
Jeder, der an dem Projekt arbeitet, bucht auf dieses Projekt und am Ende muss
das, was man da reinsteckt, möglichst vollständig die Projektanforderungen erfüllen.
Und wenn man jetzt plötzlich merkt, oh, das ist aber auch interessant,
das würde ich mir auch sehr gerne angucken, muss man manchmal leider sagen, nein, geht nicht.
Das übersteigt unser Budget, weil wir uns eben in dieser Situation befinden,
dass wir ein Unternehmen sind, was wir werden halt für unsere Aufträge auch
bezahlt vom Kunden, dafür, dass wir das liefern, was der Kunde von uns möchte.
Genau, und da kann man nicht einfach dann selber entscheiden,
ich möchte aber viel lieber das und das anschauen, sondern das muss man dann
eben so durchführen, wie das ist.
Das ist eine totale Umgewöhnung für Leute, die den universitären Betrieb gewöhnt sind.
Aber wenn man sich daran gewöhnt hat, ist es auch irgendwie gut,
weil alles, woran man arbeitet, das hat alles auch irgendwo Hand und Fuß.
Man weiß, das bringt jetzt konkret was weiter und man bewegt was.
Und das Resultat sind dann eben diese schnell voranstreitenden Studien mit den
Meilensteinen, die dann immer einen höheren Detailgrad haben.
Und man sieht auf dem Plan schon, okay, und in zwei Jahren schreiben wir hier
das Angebot und dann geht's los, dann wird was gebaut.
Was da vielleicht noch so ein Aspekt ist, dass man vielleicht auch so eine höhere
Fluktuation an Mitarbeitern hat.
Oder also so im wissenschaftlichen Bereich bleiben die Leute ja in der Regel
jahrzehntelang an den Universitäten.
Sehr viel Kontinuität.
Gibt es diese Kontinuität im...
Also mein Team ist ein relativ junges Team, aber das liegt auch daran,
dass wir in der letzten Zeit auch stark gewachsen sind.
Ich habe schon den Anspruch, dass ich hoffe, dass meine Mitarbeiter möglichst lange bei mir bleiben.
Aber ich sehe auch, dass gerade die Vorstudien eine Art Eintrittslevel sein können.
Das ist eher dran an dem, was man in der Uni gelernt hat an Space System Engineering.
Und ich habe häufig tolle, motivierte Mitarbeiter, die hier herkommen und die
dann hier anfangen und wo ich aber dann denke, vielleicht juckt die irgendwann
auch mal was und die sagen so, ich würde gerne dann mal meine Mission nicht
abgeben, sondern ich möchte dann mit,
möchte, dass die auch sehen, wie die dann gelauncht wird und dann weiterhin beteiligt sein.
Und für mich gehört es auch zur guten Führung dazu, dass ich mir anschaue,
was wollen meine Mitarbeiter.
Wenn ein Mitarbeiter zu mir sagt, ich möchte für immer hier in deiner Abteilung
bleiben, dann freue ich mich total und bin restlos dankbar.
Aber wenn eine Mitarbeiterin sagt, ich möchte gerne fünf Jahre hier sein und
oder so ungefähr drei bis fünf Jahre und dann würde ich total gerne mal in so
eine Implementierungsphase reinschnuppern,
dann bin ich auch voll und ganz dabei und unterstütze das und versuche der dann
dabei zu helfen, das zu realisieren.
Darum, ja, wir haben eine Fluktuation, aber die kann auch sehr positiv sein.
Mein Ziel ist es immer, wenn wir neue Stellen besetzen, dass wir nicht nur Leute
reinnehmen, die Berufseinsteiger sind, sondern dass wir auch mal Leute haben,
die schon eine Implementierungsphase gemacht haben und Lust haben,
mal wieder ganz von Null anzufangen,
damit man voneinander lernen kann.
Eine Sache, die mir ganz besonders aufgefallen ist, ist, ich habe ein paar Mitarbeiter,
die neben der Tätigkeit in der Vorentwicklung einen Teil ihrer Zeit bei Implementierungsprojekten
mithelfen und die können ganz viel von dem, was sie dort lernen,
transferieren in die Vorentwicklung.
Du wolltest es ja gerade verglichen mit dem universitären Betrieb,
wo man Leute hat, die jahrzehntelang dasselbe erforschen. Das gibt es bei uns eher nicht.
Es gibt Mitarbeiter, die schon sehr lange hier in der Vorentwicklung sind und
die an verschiedensten Projekten gearbeitet haben.
Das sind extrem wertvolle Leute, weil die diesen ganzen Erfahrungsschatz haben,
auf den sie zurückgreifen.
Und ich hoffe, dass die Leute, die jetzt in der Vorentwicklung bei uns sind,
dass die entweder auch hierbleiben und diesen wertvollen Schatz entwickeln oder
dass die eben einen anderen Weg einschlagen,
in unserer Firma bleiben, bei OHB bleiben, ein Projekt von Anfang bis Ende durchziehen
und dann gerne in fünf Jahren wieder bei mir in der Vorentwicklung sitzen und
nochmal von neuem anfangen.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass es viele Vorteile hat, hier zu arbeiten in so einer Struktur,
weil ja üblicherweise Firmen dann sehr viel flexibler auch entscheiden können
und in der Lage sind, mal eben etwas vielleicht mal komplett über den Haufen
zu werfen, wenn es sich einfach nicht bewährt hat, ohne dass man in diesen schwierigen,
langsam arbeitenden Rotationen von so universitätspolitischen Entscheidungen
festhängt und Mittelschwierigkeiten hat, etc.
Also das ist ja sicherlich auch ein Reiz.
Ja, das denke ich. Und ich denke auch gerade, UAB zeichnet es aus,
dass wir hier sehr, wir haben sehr flache Hierarchien und Leute,
die hierher kommen und gute Ideen mitbringen und Bock haben,
sich zu engagieren und Verantwortung zu übernehmen, die müssen nicht lange betteln
dafür. Die kriegen hier alles, was sie sich wünschen.
Ich freue mich immer, wenn ich Leute habe, die sagen, ich habe eine tolle Idee,
ich würde gerne selbstständig das und das und das machen und ich versuche das
dann auch zu ermöglichen und ich glaube, das ist generell so ein bisschen der Vibe bei uns,
dass es eben so ist, du kannst hierher kommen und du kannst dir Verantwortung
übernehmen und auch relativ schnell.
Und ich denke für manche könnte es ja auch durchaus reizvoll sein,
eben nicht lange Zeit immer am selben Projekt zu hängen, sondern im Prinzip
permanent so einen Wechsel zu haben, immer wieder was Neues zu sehen.
Also manche interessiert ja mehr das und manche interessiert mehr das.
Nicht jeder ist gleich gestrickt.
Wie läuft das? Wir haben jetzt viel drüber gesprochen, da kommt jetzt die Wissenschaft,
kommt die ESA, sagt ja hier wir wollen irgendwie das und das machen.
Da stößt man doch sicherlich auch manchmal einfach an die Grenzen des Machbaren,
wo man einfach vielleicht auch lange Zeit vor sich hinforscht,
nachdem die Machbarkeitsstudie vielleicht gesagt hat, das passt schon irgendwie alles.
Und dann soll es mal konkret werden und dann stellt man fest,
da haben wir uns aber jetzt was eingetreten.
Das hat ja dann irgendwie Reperkussionen auf alles. Wie kommuniziert man da?
Wie geht man mit solchen Fails um?
Ja, möglichst offen, auf jeden Fall. Es ist tatsächlich, das passiert.
Aber meistens ist es nicht so, dass alles verloren ist, sondern dass man einfach
so gucken muss, kann ich mit den Implikationen leben?
Also häufig hat es ja einfach direkt was mit Kosten zu tun und dann merkt man
sehr schnell, hier steigen die Kosten wahnsinnig schnell an,
die projizierten Kosten, weil das alles so furchtbar komplex ist.
Und dann kann auch mal die Reißleine gezogen werden und dann wird gesagt,
okay, stopp, wir müssen jetzt noch mal ganz neu denken.
Das passiert häufiger mal, dass man dann sagt, wir müssen noch mal neu von vorne anfangen.
Und dann kann man häufig trotzdem noch eine Mission zusammenbauen,
die dann hat dann eben Einschränkungen.
Die kann nicht mehr die und die Performance erzielen, sondern nur noch die.
Oder die kann nicht mehr in 180 Grad schauen, sondern nur noch in 60 Grad oder so was.
Aber das ist dann wieder eine Frage an die Wissenschaftler, wieder ein Zurückgespielt.
Könnt ihr damit leben, könnt ihr trotzdem noch die Forschung betreiben,
die ihr wollt und manchmal findet man dann eine ganz clevere Lösung,
wie man das, wie das dann gar nicht so schlimm ist im Nachhinein.
Ja, aber das passiert. Dafür ist das ja ganz klar da. Dafür machen wir diese
Vorstudien, um genau das zu finden, bevor es zu spät ist.
Ich hab jetzt bei verschiedenen Missionen, hat man ja auch so die Situation,
dass passiert irgendwas Unerwartetes.
Da fliegt irgendwas Richtung Saturn und dann nach fünf Jahren Flug merkt man
so, oh, hier das Instrument, das funktioniert ja gar nicht.
Jetzt haben wir hier mal so ein richtiges Problem.
Irgendwas ist komplett falsch berechnet worden. Da gibt's ja dann sicherlich
durchgeschwitzte Wochenenden.
Wie läuft da die Kommunikation ab in solchen Momenten? Also wenn sozusagen irgendwas
kaputt geht, dann ist ja wahrscheinlich auch ORB in dem Moment gefragt und muss
irgendwie auch schnell reagieren.
Werden da so Task Forces gebildet? Gibt's dann hier so eine Feuerwehrstange,
wo man runterrutscht in den Situation Room?
Also erst mal in der Vorentwicklung ist das zum Glück meistens nicht der Fall,
weil wir eben noch konzeptionell arbeiten.
Aber solche Sachen passieren auf jeden Fall. Also ein Beispiel,
was mir eingefallen ist, da war ich natürlich nicht persönlich daran beteiligt,
aber ich war dabei, ich habe das live mitbekommen, war als die Galileo -Satelliten
in den falschen Orbit gelauncht wurden.
Das war ein Riesenschock. Wir hatten eine Launchparty hier, wir waren alle zusammen,
haben fröhlich Cocktails getrunken und alle geklatscht, als es hieß so,
Launch erfolgreich und so weiter.
Und dann fing es damit an, dass es hieß, der eine Solargenerator klappt nicht aus.
Wie kann das sein? Und dann merkte man, die Stimmung wird ein bisschen komisch.
Und ja, wirklich ein Thriller. Und das hing damit zusammen, dass die Rakete
nicht diesen Spin, den sie eigentlich haben sollte.
Dadurch sind auf der einen Seite die Fuel Lines eingefroren und dadurch wurde
das Manöver nicht korrekt durchgeführt.
Und das hat auch Auswirkungen auf den Satelliten gehabt, der auf der einen Seite
eingefroren war, sodass die Pyros dich zünden konnten.
Also eingefroren, weil er nicht genug Sonne abgekriegt hat?
Genau, weil eigentlich müsste der in so einen Barbecue -Mode,
das heißt, der dreht sich die ganze Zeit, so heißt das, wie auf einem Grill.
Und das ist nicht passiert. Und dadurch ist die eine Seite warm geworden und
die andere aber eiskalt.
Und das ging alles miteinander zusammen. Aber das erste, was wir mitgekriegt
haben, war eben, der Solargenerator klappt nicht aus.
Später konnte der dann ausklappen. Und der ganze Satellit war eben dann einfach
nicht, die beiden Satelliten waren zwei auf einmal, waren nicht im korrekten
Orbit, sondern in einem niedrigeren Orbit, der auch noch elliptisch war.
Und das war sehr dramatisch. Da wurden dann sofort natürlich Leute von OHB zusammengerufen,
was machen wir jetzt, wie können wir agieren?
Und ich war nicht dabei, weil es wie gesagt nicht meine Mission war.
Aber was ich ganz cool finde, ist, später konnte man durch diesen falschen Einschuss,
bestimmte Effekte in der Relativitätstheorie zeigen, weil die haben ja diese
hochgenauen atomaren Uhren dabei und sind immer näher und weiter weg von dem
Erd -Anziehungskraft gekommen, konnten daher diese Zeitverzögerung durch die
Gravitation nachweisen.
Aber ja und die machen auch weiterhin Dienst, also die sind aber einfach in
falschen Orbit gelandet.
Also die werden nicht so die Lebensdauer haben, aber sie sind trotzdem verwendbar.
Und die sind nicht in der richtigen.
Man hat dann zwar die ephemeris von diesen Satelliten und man kann das alles
verwenden, was die produzieren, aber die Position der Satelliten ist ja so ausgewählt,
dass die eine gute Abdeckung erzielen und dadurch, dass die dann nicht in demselben Orbit sind,
können die nicht in dem Maße zur Abdeckung beitragen, wie sie das eigentlich
sollten. So war das damals.
Das ist so ein Beispiel, was mir so eingefallen ist. Es passieren auch viele,
viele andere Sachen, auch gerade halt während der Entwicklung,
wo es dann wirklich heißt, jetzt muss ganz schnell eine Lösung gefunden werden.
Und dann ist man halt einfach dabei mit dem Team. Das heißt gerade bei Launches
kann ich mir vorstellen, ist hier immer richtig Alarm?
Ja, bei Launches ist es schon fast so, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt kann man auch
nicht mehr viel ändern. Jetzt ist es halt so.
Aber gerade in dem Bereich vorher, wo gebaut und getestet wird,
wenn da irgendwas passiert, irgendwas geht kaputt beim Test und man muss es
reparieren und so, da muss man ganz schnell arbeiten. Da sind dann häufig Leute
auch sofort angerufen und du musst losfliegen jetzt.
Es gibt eine Situation. Aber da sind wir hier in der Vorentwicklung ausgenommen.
Ein weiterer Vorteil von der Vorentwicklung.
Da hat man die Ruhe, verstehe. Die Ruhe weg. Wir haben uns das alles nur ausgedacht,
ihr müsst das dann ausbaden.
Ganz ruhig ist es nicht, aber wir haben zumindest nicht diese plötzlichen Notfälle.
Jaja, es gibt ja so diese Apollo 13 Momente. Ich meine, mit bemannten Missionen,
weißt nicht, bist du schon mal an einer bemannten Mission in irgendeiner Form
beteiligt gewesen? Gibt ja auch nicht so viele jetzt.
Ne, wir haben hier mal in der Vorentwicklung, arbeiten noch weiter als OHB an
dem Projekt ESPRI, das ist diese Mondbasis.
Aber da war ich nicht dabei. Das lief in einer anderen Abteilung,
nämlich in der Exploration Abteilung hier.
Artemis hat glaube ich mit ORB nichts zu tun?
Ich glaube das hängt mit dem ASPRI Projekt auch zusammen.
Okay, naja, aber das sind ja dann nochmal ganz andere Bedingungen.
Ja, jetzt hast du ja schon mehrfach angedeutet, sowohl was deine eigene Arbeit
betrifft, eben als auch Anforderungen von Missionen generell,
dass ja so ein großes Problem eben die Beendigung der Mission ist oder wie es so schön heißt,
die, was war das, die Mission, nein, die,
Also wie wird man das wieder los? Oder salopp formuliert der Müll,
der im Weltraum so rumfliegt.
Das Ziel ist ja schon seit längerer Zeit und ich hatte ja schon mehrere Folgen
zum Thema Weltraumschrott, das Thema beschäftigt ja die ganze Szene schon seit
Jahrzehnten kann man fast sagen, aber insbesondere im letzten Jahrzehnt ist
ja eine ganze Menge gemacht worden.
ESA hat diese Space Situational Awareness Initiative gestartet,
auch um einfach erstmal sozusagen einen Blick dafür zu haben,
wo haben wir jetzt Probleme mit dem, was ist.
Aber was jetzt den Bau von Satelliten betrifft, ist ja quasi nicht nur dieses,
wie kommen wir da hin, wie kommen wir hoch, sondern wie können wir uns auch
korrekt so entsorgen, damit künftige Missionen nicht in Gefahr geraten.
Inwiefern ist das jetzt ein wichtigeres Thema geworden?
Ja, also für mich ein wahnsinnig wichtiges Thema. Ich habe das schon seit meinem
PhD, verfolge ich das eben.
Als erstes Mal bin ich damit zu richtigen Kontakt gekommen 2008,
als es diese Kollision gab.
Cosmos Iridium, da war ich noch Studentin und das war die erste Satelliten -zu
-Satelliten -Kollision im Orbit und das fand ich wow.
Also das hat mich nachhaltig Also ein Satellit des Iridium -Systems von Motorola,
damals das erste Kommunikationsnetzwerk für Satellitentelefonie.
Und das andere war ein alter oder ein ehemaliger, nicht mehr funktionierender
Kosmos -Satellit, russischer.
Und die sind halt richtig ineinander gerasselt und eine große Schrottwolke entstand
und man konnte dann richtig nachverfolgen, wie die sich dann so ausgebreitet
hat und dort auch immer noch ist. Das war auch in einer Höhe,
in der man sie nicht so schnell verschwindet.
Wo ist das dann? So 400, 500?
Ne, 700.
700 Kilometer.
Und die sieht man auch immer noch. Also jetzt in den Zahlen,
wenn man sich die Entwicklung der Weltraumschrottumgebung anguckt, da gibt es einen Sprung.
Das war dieses und dann 2009 nochmal diese absichtliche Zerstörung von einem
chinesischen Satelliten, 800 Kilometer Höhe.
Das ist jeweils ein Sprung in der Entwicklung und die pflanzt sich sofort.
Haben die das eigentlich mittlerweile mal bereut, die Chinesen?
Irgendwie nicht wirklich.
Ja, was heißt, also es gibt bestimmt einige Leute, die es furchtbar finden,
aber es gab keine offizielle Entschuldigung dafür oder sowas,
das kann man glaube ich auch lange warten.
Das Ganze ist einfach, es ist einfach sehr problematisch und es macht mir auch große Sorgen.
Ich versuche auch mal das zu erzählen, warum das für uns jetzt in der Wissenschaft
so besonders problematisch ist, weil die Satelliten und die Instrumente,
die wir bauen, die sind Die sind sehr teuer, die werden lange entwickelt, 20 Jahre oder so.
Dann hat man ein Teleskop da oben.
Das soll uns 20 Jahre wissenschaftliche Daten liefern.
Das Risiko, dass das getroffen und zerstört wird, wird immer größer,
je mehr diese Weltraumschrottumgebung wächst.
Meine große Sorge ist, dass wir irgendwann wo hinkommen, wo es sich nicht mehr
rechnet, so viel Geld zu investieren. Weil man sagt, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass das Ding innerhalb von ein paar Jahren zerstört wird, ist einfach zu hoch.
Und das kann man dem Steuerzahler nicht zumuten, dafür Geld auszugeben.
Bzw. selbst wenn es nicht getroffen wird, muss man ja die ganze Zeit ausweichen,
dafür dann wieder Treibstoff verbrauchen, was ja dann die Emissionsdauer verkürzt.
Genau. Oder es könnte auch getroffen werden von kleinen Partikeln,
die es zwar nicht zerstören, aber die einfach die Funktionalität stark beeinträchtigen.
Solarpanele zerlöchern etc.
Genau. Oder auf die Optik oder sowas. Darum ist das für mich so wichtig,
dieses Thema und seit ich bei UHB bin, begleitet es mich hier schon.
Ich war erst in der Erdbeobachtung als Systemingenieurin und das war 2012,
da bin ich zu UHB gekommen und das war das Jahr,
in dem die ISO -Standard, ISO 24113 heißt das, das ist der Weltraumschrott -Mitigierungsstandard,
Da sind die ganzen Anforderungen drin, wie in 25 Jahren soll man die orbiten und so.
Der wurde durch die ECSS anwendbar für ESA -Missionen.
Und das heißt, das war das erste Mal, dass wir wirklich so von Kundenseite standardmäßig
feste Anforderungen an die Weltraumschrott -Disposal hatten und da habe ich
von Anfang an dann immer in unseren Missionen, in den Vorstudien,
da diese Weltraumschrott -Pläne erstellt und habe dann 2017, fünf Jahre später,
16 oder 17 war das, habe ich dieses Weltraumschrott -Kompetenzzentrum gegründet,
weil ich gemerkt habe, es gibt ganz viele Leute innerhalb der Firma in den verschiedenen
Abteilungen sitzen, die alle irgendwas mit Weltraumschrott zu tun haben,
aber die reden nicht miteinander.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel in der Antriebsabteilung gibt es jemanden,
der kümmert sich darum, dass Antriebe passiviert werden, also dass man am Ende
den letzten Spritz rauslässt, damit es da keine Möglichkeit gibt, dass es explodiert.
Oder dann gibt es jemanden in der Missionsanalyse, der berechnet Wiedereintrittsmanöver.
Und dann gibt es uns hier in der Vorentwicklung und wir machen das Ganze für
die neuen Satelliten, dass wir die so auslegen.
Und die haben alle nicht miteinander so richtig geredet.
Und darum dieses Kompetenzzentrum, wo man sich einmal im Monat austauscht,
über die neuesten Entwicklungen spricht, auf technischer Ebene,
aber auch auf programmatischer Ebene.
Und das hat jetzt zuletzt richtig Fahrt aufgenommen, weil es jetzt innerhalb
von Europa viele Initiativen gibt, an dem Problem endlich was zu lösen.
Und ich glaube ausschlaggebend dafür ist diese neue Entwicklung mit den Megakonstellationen.
So neu ist jetzt auch nicht mehr, aber es gibt ja jetzt einfach tausende von
Satellitenlaunches pro Jahr.
Also vor allem Starlink, aber nicht nur Starlink, aber das ist natürlich das bekannteste Beispiel.
Tausende Arbeit, also wirklich bis in der Endausbaustufe glaube ich bis zu 40 .000.
Satelliten.
Allein Starlink hat ja jetzt schon mehr Satelliten gelauncht,
als insgesamt in der gesamten Geschichte der Weltraumfahrt vorher gelauncht wurden.
Die waren natürlich viel kleiner, aber eben viele.
Ja, aber das Problem ist ja die Anzahl und nicht die Größe. Also die Größe ist
auch problematisch insofern, dass wenn ein großer Satellit explodiert oder getroffen
wird, dann erzeugt er mehr Schrott.
Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit eine Kollision zu haben, wächst mit der Anzahl der Objekte.
Starlink ist ein Beispiel, aber es gibt viele andere. Amazon hat auch eine eigene
Konstellation, es gibt auch Konstellationen aus allen Teilen der Welt,
die jetzt entwickelt werden, chinesische Konstellationen und so weiter.
Das ist nicht wirklich reguliert, das ist nicht wirklich geklärt, wie man das…,
wie man das handhaben will. Ein großes Problem mit Konstellationen ist,
die fliegen meistens in einem ähnlichen Orbit, also in einer gleichen orbitalen Schicht.
Und wenn jetzt die Mission beendet wird und die nicht korrekt entsorgt werden,
dann sind die so nah beieinander, dass eine Kollision ganz wahrscheinlich ist.
Und wenn erstmal eine Kollision eingetreten ist, dann hat man diese Kettenreaktion,
diesen Kessler -Effekt, wo dann ganz schnell die ganze orbitale Schicht vermüllt ist.
Und ja, und da engagiere ich mich halt eben schon ziemlich lange für und mache das auch hier weiter.
Und wir wollen, also als UHB ist es für uns eben total wichtig,
weil das ist ja unser Kernfeld, sind ja diese großen, teuren,
hochwertigen Satelliten.
Und das sind eben genau die, die auch am meisten da zu verlieren haben.
Wenn man Satelliten baut, die klein und günstig sind und in großer Masse zu
produzieren sind, dann ist es nicht so schlimm in Anführungsstrichen,
wenn davon einer mal kaputt geht.
Weil man hat ja noch viele andere oder im Notfall macht man halt einen neuen.
Aber wenn man diese großen teuren Produkte anguckt, die konventionelle Raumfahrt,
die Wissenschaftsmissionen, die haben am meisten zu verlieren.
Wer nimmt an dem Kompetenzzentrum so alles teil? Ist das eher eine europäische
oder nur deutsche Geschichte oder ist das schon international?
Also das ist ein OHB, ein internes Kompetenzzentrum.
Und wir haben aber Kontakte auch zu unseren anderen Partnern,
also unseren Schwesterfirmen in anderen europäischen Ländern.
Aber die regulären Teilnehmer sind alle von der OHB System und von der OHB DC,
das ist Digital Connect.
Die machen Bodensysteme und Operations.
Aber wir arbeiten, das ist innerhalb der Firma, Da arbeiten wir daran,
unsere Satelliten zu verbessern und Technologien zu entwickeln und so.
Aber wir haben auch Kontakte und wir arbeiten eng zusammen mit der ESA,
mit dem DLR, auch mit anderen Industrieunternehmen.
Einmal über zum Beispiel Eurospace, das ist so eine Vereinigung von Industrieunternehmen,
aber auch ganz besonders über das Clean Space Office der ESA.
Das ist in ESA eine Initiative, wo es darum geht, die Raumfahrt nachhaltiger
zu machen und die ganz viel im direkten Austausch mit der Industrie gehen,
was ich richtig super finde und wo wir immer,
wo wir schon ganz viele Fortschritte gemacht haben.
Jetzt in diesem Jahr steht ganz oben auf der Agenda die sogenannte Zero Debris
Charter, das ist ein politisches Dokument,
wo sich Industrie und ESA und verschiedene nationale Weltraumorganisationen wie DLR zum Beispiel.
Zusammenschließen und gemeinsam einen Plan, einen groben Plan entwickeln, wo wir 2030 sein wollen.
Was zum Beispiel die Zuverlässigkeit von Satelliten im Wiedereintritt angeht und so weiter.
Was ist denn bisher schon so erzielt worden an Fortschritten?
Wir haben vielleicht mal ein paar Jahre zurück geblättert. Was ist jetzt besser
an den Satelliten, was ist geändert worden, um diese ganzen Zielsetzungen dann
auch zu erfüllen und diese Wünsche umzusetzen?
Also in unseren Satelliten sind wir compliant, also erfüllen wir diese Mitigationsvorschriften,
das heißt, die werden immer so ausgelegt, dass sie am Ende der operationellen Lebensdauer,
entweder kontrolliert einen Wiedereintritt durchführen oder einen passiven Wiedereintritt
machen und davor sich passivieren.
Und dass man die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer Explosion oder so minimiert,
dass die Ausweichmanöver fliegen.
Also ganz viele Sachen sind einfach jetzt im Design standardmäßig dabei.
Was man noch nicht so richtig sehen kann, ist, was für Auswirkungen das hat,
weil die Satelliten, die jetzt fliegen und vor allem die jetzt in ihr End -of
-Life gehen, die sind häufig von der Zeit, bevor es diese Standards gab.
Und wenn man sich das anschaut, sieht man, es sind nur ganz wenige Satelliten,
die wirklich einen Wiedereintritt machen oder ein wirkliches End -of -Life -Betrieb durchführen.
Das heißt, es geht jetzt eigentlich erst langsam los.
Ich glaube, die Früchte zeigen sich erst jetzt so langsam. Und das ist halt
so, wenn ich jetzt anfange, einen Satelliten zu entwerfen, dann wird der vielleicht 2029 gelauncht.
Und dann hat er sein End -of -Life vielleicht 2038.
Und das heißt also 15 Jahre.
Aber irgendwas wird auch schon mal runtergekommen sein, was schon so halbwegs modern gedacht war.
Ja klar, also es gab schon Wiedereintritte, die gezielt waren.
Es gab auch schon passive Wiedereintritte, aber einfach die Compliance -Rate ist so niedrig.
Es gibt einfach viel zu viele Satelliten, die dort oben am Ende des Lebens einfach
nur das Licht ausmachen und da oben bleiben statt sich zu entfernen.
Aber ich glaube halt in vielen Fällen, weil sie eben aus einer Zeit stammen,
wo das noch nicht mit eingebaut wurde in das System.
Und das andere, was sich gerade tut, was total eine krasse Entwicklung ist,
wo ich auch echt überrascht bin, dass das jetzt kommt, weil es immer hieß,
kommerziell kriegt man das nicht hin, also es gibt einfach nicht genug Budget
dafür ist, dass man eine Debris -Removal -Mission macht.
Das ist ja hier Clear Space One und auch Astroscale, eine Firma aus Japan und
Großbritannien, macht jetzt einen echten Demonstrator von einer Mission,
die da hochfliegt und sich eine alte,
Raketenoberstufe schnappt und aus dem Orbit entfernt.
Das ist jetzt erstmal so eine Technologiedemonstration.
Gibt es da eine Technologie, die sich da abzeichnet?
Ich hatte ja schon mehrfach das Thema, einerseits die Weltraumschrott Sendung,
da haben wir natürlich darüber gesprochen, vor allem über das Problem selber,
dass wir über Robotik gesprochen haben.
Dann kam es auch schon zu Überlegungen für automatische Andockungen.
Jedes Raumfahrzeug hat ja in der Regel zum Beispiel eine Antriebsdüse.
Da könnte man ja vielleicht von hinten sich einklinken.
Mit Netzen wird experimentiert. Zeichnet sich schon irgendeine Technologie ab,
wo alle meinen, das könnte am besten funktionieren, das ist vielleicht der ökonomischste
Ansatz oder ist das noch ein sehr breites Feld, wo eigentlich alles mal ausprobiert
werden muss, wie es funktionieren könnte mit der Müllabfuhr?
Also ich glaube am vielversprechendsten ist dieses feste Docking,
also wo man wirklich hinfliegt und zum Beispiel mit der Düse sich verbindet
oder mit dem Launch Vehicle Adapter, also dem Ring, mit dem man vorher schon
auf dem Launcher befestigt war, weil das ist natürlich fest auch an der Struktur befestigt.
Und der ist auch halbwegs standardisiert.
Genau, der ist auch standardisiert. Aber was wir auch haben,
ist, dass wir mit den neuen Satelliten so Docking -Stations einbauen,
sodass die schon richtig so einen Greifpunkt haben und so ein kleines Schild,
was man dafür benutzen kann,
um mit einem visuellen Sensor zu erkennen, in welcher Lage befindet sich der
Satellit gerade, wie dreht er sich.
So ein QR -Code sozusagen.
Ja, so ein bisschen so, genau, und das wird jetzt mit eingebaut,
sodass man, falls der Satellit es nicht schaffen sollte, aus eigener Kraft den
Wiedereintritt zu machen, dass
man die Option hat, ein möglichst einfaches Dockinginterface zu haben.
Aber das ist natürlich das eigentliche Ziel, dass so eine Rettungsmission gar
nicht erst erforderlich ist.
Trotzdem kann ich mir vorstellen, dass der Bedarf für diese Müllabfuhr steigt.
Weil ich meine da müssen ja eigentlich auch die Unternehmen selber ein Interesse dran haben.
Also gerade als wir Starlink angesprochen haben, ich meine das ist natürlich für die in dem Moment,
wo einer ihrer Satelliten da rogue läuft und irgendwie alles so kegelmäßig wegballert,
kann er ja auch mal schnell den Tod des ganzen, vielleicht nicht des ganzen,
aber zumindest signifikanter Teile des Netzes bedeuten.
Bis hin zur Gefährdung des Weiterbetriebs an sich, weil wenn erstmal genug rumfliegt,
dann muss man unter Umständen den ganzen Orbit ja aufgeben und später dann vielleicht
auch noch andere orbitale Lagen.
Beteiligen die sich da? Gibt es da Innovationen?
Also für Betreiber von einer festen Konstellation ist es vielleicht so,
dass man tatsächlich sagt, okay, ihr habt ein Interesse daran,
den Satelliten zu entfernen.
Aber man muss leider sagen, in den allermeisten Fällen ist der Betreiber nicht
derjenige, der direkt betroffen ist von den Folgen.
Es kann sein, aber erst mal ist das einfach nur eine Umweltverschmutzung in dem Sinne.
Und das muss meiner Meinung nach, das muss viel strenger reguliert werden,
dass man wirklich dafür aufkommen muss. Wir haben jetzt bei der Zero -Debris
-Charta darüber gesprochen, dass wir mit 99 -prozentiger Wahrscheinlichkeit
eigentlich wollen, dass die Satelliten nicht im Orbit verbleiben.
Und das ist eigentlich nur möglich, indem man Vorkehrungen trifft,
dass man im Falle eines Ausfalls eben so einen Rettungsdienst nutzt.
Anders weiß ich nicht, wie man eine 99 -prozentige Wahrscheinlichkeit erreichen
soll, weil es eben immer was gibt, was ausfallen kann.
Oder man muss den Satelliten so designen, dass er alle Systeme dreimal oder
so dabei hat, was ja dann auch wirklich teuer wird.
Ja.
Normalerweise so im industriellen Bereich, Kraftwerke etc.
Macht man das ja mit so einem Fonds, wo man sozusagen sagt,
okay ihr wollt in diesem Milieu wirtschaftlich unterwegs sein,
könnt ihr das schön machen,
aber wenn ihr hier eine Lizenz haben wollt, dann müsst ihr irgendwie so und
so viel Prozent von eurem Umsatz in so einen Topf geben und wenn halt mal wirklich
was schief geht, dann haben wir zumindest Kohle, um das irgendwie regeln zu können.
Zeichnet sich das ab, dass sowas kommt?
Also die Idee gibt es, aber das Problem ist, wie setzt man das um?
Bei einem Kraftwerk hat man ein festes Land, in dem soll das Kraftwerk dann
stehen und da gibt es halt eine klare legislative Hoheit.
Und das gibt es im Weltraum eben nicht und man müsste sich dann schon wirklich
international einig werden.
Wenn einige Länder anfangen würden, das alleine zu machen, kann das halt auch
einfach eine Abwanderung von Industrie bedeuten.
So nach dem Motto, wenn das hier zu teuer wird, dann launchen wir halt woanders. Ja, genau.
Eine Idee, die schon mal besprochen wurde, war, dass man vielleicht das auch
mit den Servicen verbinden sollte.
Also nicht so sehr guckt, wo wird der gelauncht oder wo wird er betrieben,
sondern wo dürfen die ihre Services verkaufen.
Wenn man einen Satelliten hat, der zum Beispiel Internet anbietet,
aber keine korrekten Vorkehrungen für End of Life hat, dann darf der vielleicht
sein Internet nicht in Europa vertreiben. Nur so als Idee.
Ja, okay, good point.
Das könnte ein interessanter Hebel sein natürlich und Tracking Station,
solche Netzwerke nutzen zu können, ist natürlich auch in gewisser Hinsicht ein
Privileg, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Ja das stimmt, genau. Also Bodenstationsnetzwerke und so.
Obwohl gerade die Konstellationen, die haben eigentlich Inter -Satellite -Link,
also da braucht man dann nur noch eine Bodenstation und die Informationen werden
dann von Satellit zu Satellit weitergegeben.
Beziehungsweise sie haben halt überhaupt ihre eigene Infrastruktur auf dem Boden.
Ja, alles nicht so einfach. Aber du bist da optimistisch, dass sich da was tut?
Ja, also irgendwas muss sich tun.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das unbedingt als optimistisch bezeichnen würde.
Was ich gut finde, ist, man hat das Gefühl, im Moment ist wirklich Impuls dahinter.
Wir merken von vielen Seiten, es gibt Interesse, die deutsche Raumfahrtstrategie
nimmt speziell auf Nachhaltigkeit Bezug.
Wir haben von der EU, hören wir jetzt, dass es im EU Space Law Nachhaltigkeit
mit berücksichtigt werden soll.
Dann haben wir wie gesagt dieser Zero Debris Charter, wo wir,
was auch wirklich außergewöhnlich ist, dass wir da mit Industrie übergreifend,
mit unseren Wettbewerbern, mit unseren Kunden alle zusammen unterzeichnen wollen,
dass wir uns hier an bestimmte Maßstäbe halten wollen.
Und eben ist es auch Geld da, um solche Entwicklungen zu finanzieren.
Was früher wirklich in Frage stand, wo wir gesagt haben, das wird nie kommen,
so eine Mission, weil es gibt einfach niemanden, der bereit ist,
so viel Geld dafür zu bezahlen, einen Satelliten aus dem Orbit zu entfernen.
Und jetzt passiert es doch.
Und es gibt eben auch Geld da, um Technologien zu entwickeln,
die wir brauchen. Sprich dieses Das Design vor dem Mais, was ich eben angesprochen hatte.
Wann kommt diese Testmission an den Start, die nächste?
Ich glaube, es sollte 2026 soweit sein, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Also nicht mehr lange.
Okay, nicht mehr lange, aber halt so nicht mehr lange in Raumfahrtsgrößenordnung.
Ja, voll bald in Raumfahrtsgrößenordnung.
Das ist ja quasi morgen schon.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, man muss ja hier wirklich einen langen Atem haben. Du hast EU -Space -Law
angesprochen, das heißt es soll auf der Ebene der Europäischen Union einen Weltraum...
Gesetzgebung erarbeitet werden, die dann das Potenzial hat, als Vorlage für
die internationalen Verhandlungen zu dienen oder wie sehe ich das?
Also ich bin gar keine Expertin, was diese EU -Machenschaften angeht und ich
finde es auch immer super komplex, aber wie ich es verstehe,
ist, dass die EU eine Art Vorschlag dann macht und die Nationalstaaten das in
ihre eigene Gesetzgebung übernehmen können,
aber genau, das ist, ich bin Ingenieurin.
Ja, ist mir schon klar. Aber interessanter Hinweis hatte ich jetzt noch gar
nicht so auf dem Zeiger. Ich habe mich ja schon mal über Weltraumrecht unterhalten,
das ist aber schon eine Weile her.
Wobei auch damals war schon klar, dass es einfach sehr schwierig ist die Interessen
unterschiedlicher Staaten hier unter einen Hut zu bringen.
Und wenn man sich halt vor allem die Ambitionen der Russen in den letzten Jahren
anschaut, könnte es ein bisschen schwierig werden da auf einen gemeinsamen Nenner zu kommen.
China ist ja auch generell noch so ein bisschen ausgeklingt,
aber wäre natürlich schon mal ganz gut, wenn es hier zumindest mal sinnvolle Vorschläge gibt.
Aber ich finde auch, das ist für mich auch immer so ein Punkt,
ich vergleiche das ganz gerne so mit der Klimawandel -Problematik.
Man kann nicht immer nur sagen, aber die Russen, aber die Chinesen machen es
doch auch, weil dann kommt man nie weiter.
Wir müssen als Industrienation, müssen wir auch eine Vorbildfunktion erfüllen
und das gilt jetzt auch für den Weltraumschrott, aber halt ganz besonders mit dem Klimawandel.
Und wenn man sich anschaut, was fliegt denn da oben eigentlich rum?
Ja klar, es gibt viel russischen Schrott, aber es gibt auch ganz,
ganz viel Schrott aus Amerika und auch einiges aus Europa.
Und die aufstrebenden Nationen im Bereich Raumfahrt, die jetzt anfangen,
die gucken ja auch, wie verhalten sich die Player?
Und wenn wir jetzt sagen, na ja, okay, wir haben keinen richtigen Grund,
da jetzt wirklich was zu machen, weil es halten sich ja sowieso nicht alle dran,
Dann ist es ja kein Wunder, dass eine neue Raumfahrtnation, sagen wir mal Nigeria oder so,
dann auch nicht sagt, okay, wir machen jetzt aber sehr, sehr nachhaltige Raumfahrt.
Ich meine, toll, wenn sie es tun, aber ja, ich finde, da ist es schon sehr,
sehr wichtig, dass gerade als eine Nation, die schon sehr viel entwickelt hat
und die auch schon viel genutzt hat im Orbit und davon auch schon viel profitiert
hat, dass man eben den Weg weist.
Mh.
Ja, also ich glaube da haben alle so ein bisschen Dreck am Stecken,
weil das Thema einfach lange Zeit vernachlässigt wurde.
Ich frage mich eigentlich immer, warum eigentlich? Also hat man irgendwie lange
Zeit gedacht, das könnte nicht wirklich ein Problem sein?
Oder sind da einfach nur die frühen Rufe nie erhört worden aus Kostengründen?
Oder war einfach das Wachstum dann schneller, als alle damit gerechnet haben?
Beides. Also einmal hat man lange Zeit nicht geglaubt, dass es ein wirkliches
Problem gibt, obwohl der Donald Kessler das ja schon in den 70er Jahren prognostiziert hat.
Aber das sind natürlich auch immer dieser Kommunikationsunterschied zwischen
den Wissenschaftlern und den Leuten, die dann Satelliten tatsächlich auch in
Auftrag geben, was früher ganz oft auch das Militär einfach war.
Und dann zum Beispiel diese Antisatellitentests, da ist man sich ja eigentlich
einig, dass das Quatsch ist, aber trotzdem wurde das weitergemacht.
Der letzte ist jetzt auch erst ein paar Jahre her, wo eben Satelliten wirklich
im Orbit zerstört werden, um zu demonstrieren, wir können das.
Die Leute, die das entscheiden, die haben bestimmt nicht schlaflose Nächte wegen Weltraumschrott.
Das sind einfach ganz andere Interessen, die da zusammenkommen.
Und das andere ist diese Entwicklung mit den Megakonstellationen,
das hat viele überrascht.
Das ändert alles in der Weltraumindustrie, das hatten wir, also ich hatte das
so nicht auf dem Schirm und bis vor ein paar Jahren eben. Und dann plötzlich ging das los.
Und wir haben gesehen, es geht nicht nur darum, dass hier ein paar Universitäten
CubeSats machen, sondern es geht darum, dass wirklich im ganz großen,
im kommerziellen Stil zehntausende von Satelliten in den Orbit geschossen werden.
Und nicht nur von einer Firma, sondern von vielen, die das machen wollen.
Einige, die es jetzt auch schon machen und noch viel, viel mehr, die es planen zu machen.
Und dann ändert es einfach alles. Wenn man sich die Wenn man sich die Diagramme
anschaut, es gibt so ein paar Diagramme, die wirklich augenöffnend sind,
wo man sieht, seit den 60er -Jahren, wie viele Launchs gab es und wie viele
gab es in den letzten beiden Jahren.
Und das sind einfach ein Balkendiagramm, wo es in den Himmel reißt auf einmal.
Und dann, wenn man das dann noch vergrößert in die Zukunft und guckt,
wie viele sind jetzt schon angekündigt, da ist eine ganz klare Schnittstelle
im Jahr 2020 ungefähr oder 2019. sind.
Und da ist der große Umbruch und wir haben viel, viel, viel mehr Launches jetzt,
als wir es jemals zuvor hatten.
Es gibt ja ein paar richtige Klopper. Also vor allem sind ja früher,
also der Trend zu kleineren Satelliten ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch gut,
auch wenn es jetzt so viele sind.
Früher hat man ja noch ein anderes Modell gehabt und es gibt ja einige große Satelliten.
Ich glaube so ein 6 Tonnen Teil InchelSat, der da verendet ist.
Und der Envisat auch noch natürlich. Also der ist ja noch schwerer,
irgendwie über 8 Tonnen. Also wirklich so ein VW -Bus im Weltall.
Die so ein bisschen unkontrolliert da rumliegen. Es wären ja eigentlich,
sagen wir mal, sehr dankenswerte Ziele für so eine Rettungsmission.
Aber man kann wahrscheinlich an diese dicken Dinger, also ist es schwerer?
Oder eigentlich das gleiche wie bei so einem kleinen?
Ich meine so ein kleiner ist vielleicht schwerer einzufangen und letztlich so
viel Energie brauchen wir ja gar nicht, um die Dinger auf einen anderen Orbit zu bringen, oder?
Ja, also erst mal die großen Teile. Also es gibt so eine Art Hitliste,
so eine Art Most Wanted List von Objekten,
wo man sehen kann, welche muss man auf jeden Fall einfangen und das hat damit
zu tun, was ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die mal explodieren oder zerstört
werden und was ist der schwere Grad von den Folgen von so einer Explosion.
Und da steht Envisa zum Beispiel ganz oben, weil es eben in einem Orbit,
er ist in einem Orbit 800 Kilometer, wo der ganz wichtig ist für die Erdbeobachtung,
der aber so weit oben ist, dass man kaum noch Restatmosphäre hat.
Also wenn es dann… Da bremst nichts ab.
Da bremst nichts mehr ab. Der bleibt dann tausende von Jahren dort.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er mal explodiert, durch eine Kollision zerstört
wird, ist extrem hoch, weil er eben von alleine kaum runterkommt,
in Hunderten von Jahren nicht.
Aber es gibt auch andere Satelliten, die da weit oben stehen,
die zum Beispiel volatile Antriebssysteme dabei haben, wo man weiß,
früher oder später explodieren die.
Und der Grund, warum man sich nicht als allererstes Envisat schnappt,
ist, Envisat ist wie gesagt ein Acht -Tonnen -Klopper und wenn man den nicht
auf eine ganz gezielte Wiedereintrittsbahn auf die Erde befördert,
sondern wenn da irgendwas schieflaufen würde,
dann würde der sehr, sehr viele Komponenten,
die den Wiedereintritt überleben, auf der Erdoberfläche zerstreuen mit hoher Geschwindigkeit.
Das kann also sehr gefährlich werden für Menschen, für Tiere,
für Einrichtungen, für Infrastruktur auf dem Boden.
Also den muss man auf einer sehr klugen Trajektorie direkt in den Pazifik führen sozusagen.
Da muss man erstmal demonstriert haben, dass man das kann und dass man das auch
wirklich sicher kann, bevor sich das irgendjemand traut.
Okay, aber eigentlich ist das schon so Target Nummer eins. Das wäre super,
wenn man dem mal los wird.
Für Europa ist es das, weil es ist ein europäischer Satellit.
Das heißt wir wissen, wir können da ran, ohne dass irgendjemand ein Problem damit hat.
Es gibt viele andere Satelliten, die auch große Probleme verursachen,
wo das rechtlich nicht so einfach ist, wo die einfach nicht europäisches Eigentum sind.
Genau, wie zum Beispiel dieser Intelsat, der auch so ein Riesending ist.
Wie sieht das aus mit den geostationären Orbits, weil ich meine,
die Low, oder Low, ich weiß nicht, bis zu 800 Kilometer, wie nennt man dann
den Orbit noch, das ist ja nicht mehr Low. Also sagen wir mal so die Erdnaheit.
Ne Low, Leo ist bis 2000 Kilometer höher.
Also in diesem Leo Bereich, also da wo man eine realistische Chance hat mit
überschaubarem Energieaufwand die Dinge auch wieder nach unten zu zwingen,
weil eigentlich bringt die ja nichts aus der Ruhe.
Die fliegen da einfach ihre Bahn und folgen einfach Einstein um die Erde herum,
das heißt man muss da einfach gegendrücken, um die sozusagen wieder so ein bisschen
wie eine Gummiente unter Wasser zu halten.
Und dann gibt es aber noch diesen geostationären Orbit, da ist ja die Chance,
die wieder zurück zu bekommen, kann man irgendwie komplett vergessen und die
heutige Strategie sieht ja so aus, dass die dann einfach ein bisschen weiter
rausgeschoben werden, aber im Prinzip ja da auch bleiben.
Genau, beim GEO das ist ein ganz spezieller Orbit, weil das ist ja nur ein Orbit.
Also beim LEO haben wir ganz viele verschiedene Orbits, hohe Inklination,
niedrige Inklination, die so kreuz und quer durcheinander flitzen.
Das ist ganz chaotisch. Im Geo ist es so, die sind alle ungefähr äquatorial
und die gehen alle in die selbe Richtung und mit derselben Geschwindigkeit,
weil die alle diesen 24 Stunden Umlauf haben wollen, wo sie immer über einen Punkt der Erde stehen.
Ein Perlenkettchen einmal die ganze Erde herum.
Und wenn jetzt einer davon anfängt nicht mehr zu funktionieren und anfängt abzudriften,
dann hat der nur eine ganz geringe relative Geschwindigkeit zu den anderen,
weil der geht dann ein bisschen niedriger und dann.
Im Verhältnis zu den anderen bewegt er sich dann so ganz leise ein bisschen
rückwärts oder ein bisschen vorwärts, je nachdem und die Kollisionsrisiken dort
sind erstmal ein bisschen in der Hinsicht geringer, dass die relative Geschwindigkeit geringer ist.
Das ist wichtig zu berücksichtigen, weil wenn man zwei polare Satelliten im
Leo hat, die sich begegnen, möglichst noch frontal, dann kann man hier sieben
Kilometer pro Sekunde, da sieben Kilometer pro Sekunde, 14 Kilometer pro Sekunde
zusammenprallen haben.
Im Geo bewegt man sich mit dreieinhalb Kilometer pro Sekunde,
also schon mal langsamer und dann eben halt relativ.
Und dann hat man vielleicht so was ein paar hundert Meter pro Sekunde Relativgeschwindigkeit,
eine ganz andere Nummer.
Und dann, dadurch, dass das nur ein Donut ist, in dem sich der Geo befindet,
kann man eben auf diesen Graveyarding -Orbit gehen,
der einige hundert Kilometer höher ist und der dann auch prognostiziert erstmal
keine Überschneidungen mehr mit dem Geo hat.
Und das ist eine ganz gute Methode, die Geosatelliten zu entsorgen.
Und ich glaube, da bleibt man auch bei, weil die in den Wiedereintritt zu zwingen, ist sehr komplex,
kostet sehr viel Treibstoff und birgt auch gewisse Risiken, weil die sind sehr
groß und man muss halt schon genau zielen, wenn man von 36 .000 Kilometer Entfernung
genau einen kleinen Fleck im Pazifischen Ozean treffen möchte.
Und was wir aber besonders interessant finden, oder was ich auch besonders interessant
finde, ist dieses On -Orbit -Servicing,
also dass man Satelliten baut, die zu Geosatelliten hinfliegen und die wieder
fit machen, wenn da irgendwas ausgefallen ist, versucht das zu reparieren, also quasi Drohnen,
Reparatur -Drohnen, die dort im Orbit die Satelliten wieder ansatzfähig machen
oder wenn Hopfen und Malz verloren ist, die abschleppen und dann eben nicht
zum Boden abschleppen, sondern in den Graveyard bringen.
Also ich höre schon eine gewisse Hoffnung raus, dass diese Reparaturmissionen
demnächst ein richtiges Thema werden.
Ja, also es gab ja schon einen erfolgreichen Einsatz von einer Reparaturmission
im Orbit, im Geo. Nicht von uns, aber es gab es.
Und ich glaube, das wird immer wichtiger werden, auch unter Aspekten der Nachhaltigkeit.
Ganz viel von dem Material, was wir da hochschicken, das wird im Moment einfach
ungenutzt, verbrannt oder entsorgt oder in den Graveyard gebracht.
Aber wenn ich mir vorstelle, was machen wir in 20, 30 oder 40 Jahren?
Das ist ja viel, viel Zeit und viel Entwicklung, die da weitergeht.
Ich kann mir kaum vorstellen, dass wir weiter so mit dem Material umgehen,
was wir teuer in den Orbit befördert haben.
Darauf hinauslaufen, dass man im Orbit anfängt, die Sachen weiterzuverwenden,
wiederzuverwenden, reuse, recycle, etc.
Oder eben auch eine Art der Rückführung vielleicht erfindet,
die auch eine Wiedernutzung der Materialien beinhaltet.
Weil ich meine, oft sind ja auch sehr seltene Stoffe in diesen komplexen Instrumenten,
die jetzt nicht so üppig vielleicht vorhanden sind. und vielleicht noch,
aber irgendwann vielleicht auch nicht mehr.
Es ist ja generell nicht einfach etwas zurückzuführen. Also wir reden ja immer
von, okay der Orbit muss frei sein, aber am Ende bedeutet das ja dann meistens,
dass das meiste verglüht.
Dann ist es ja auch erstmal gleichförmig über den Pazifik verstreut und von
daher auch nicht so ohne weiteres wieder nutzbar.
Gibt es denn eigentlich technologisch in irgendeiner Form neue Ansätze,
dass diese Ateliten auch bewusst überleben und in irgendeiner Form bergbar sind?
Oder ist das dann zu viel des Guten?
Also meiner ist Wissensnach nicht. Aber ich glaube auch das Wertvollste im Moment
an den Materialien ist nicht das Material, sondern dass sie im Orbit sind.
Weil wir bezahlen ja 50 .000 Euro oder so für ein Kilogramm Launchmasse und
das ist ein Kilogramm Aluminium, das ist jetzt schon im Orbit.
Da muss ich nicht nochmal 50 .000 Euro für bezahlen. Ich müsste eigentlich nur
hinkommen, das bergen, das in ein Aluminiumgranulat umwandeln und daraus neuen Satelliten drucken.
Also ich rede jetzt mal von 20, 30 Jahren, aber technologisch ist das keine
Magie, so was müsste machbar sein und ich glaube eben, oder eben Komponenten,
die man nimmt und repariert und wiederverwendet.
Das ist jetzt nichts, was in den nächsten paar Jahren kommen wird,
aber ich glaube, das ist einfach etwas, was unweigerlich kommt,
weil es eben im Moment eine ganz große Verschwendung ist von dem,
was wir alles schon drumherum haben.
Aber ist nicht eigentlich die Laufzeit vor allem auch einfach nur durch einen
Mangel an Treibstoff definiert?
Also oft funktionieren die Dinger ja dann eigentlich auch noch ganz gut,
aber ihnen ist halt einfach der Treibstoff ausgegangen.
So Refueling, dass man einfach da mal so einen Weltraumtanklastwagen durch die
Gegend schickt, das müsste ja eigentlich auch eine Option sein.
Klar, das ist auch ein Teil von diesem On -Orbit -Servicing.
Wir arbeiten auch gerade an einem ganz spannenden Projekt für ESPRI,
für diese Mondstation mit dem Xenon -Refueling, wo man Xenon -Gas neu einbaut,
damit man eben diese Raumstation weiterverwenden kann.
Aber auch ganz normales Hydrazine -Refueling und so ist Teil von diesem On -Orbit -Servicing.
Aber es ist nicht nur das. Die Satelliten haben ja alle Komponenten dabei und
diese Komponenten sind auf eine bestimmte Lebensdauer ausgelegt.
Und im All sind nochmal erschwerte Bedingungen. Man hat da höhere Strahlungslasten
und so weiter. Und es ist einfach so, nach einer Weile gehen die Dinger kaputt.
So oder so. Oder auch Sachen, die sich bewegen, Mechanismen oder wir hatten
vorhin die Schwungenräder oder so.
Die sind für eine gewisse Anzahl von Zyklen ausgelegt und irgendwann gehen die kaputt.
Aber wie gesagt, vielleicht kann man sie ja auch reparieren,
vielleicht kann man ja was machen oder sie ausbauen und umbauen oder neu verwenden.
Das würde aber natürlich auch einen höheren Grad an Modularisierung,
Standardisierung, Schnittstellen etc.
Dass man da einfach mal neue Solarpanele ranschraubt oder so.
Das sind ja alles komplexe, delikate Verbindungen heutzutage,
die sich nicht so ohne weiteres und schon gar nicht durch einen Roboter im Weltall
so ohne weiteres auflösen lassen. Aber da könnte es ja hingehen.
Da könnte es ja hingehen, genau.
Könnte es ja hingehen. The future is still bright.
Ja Charlotte, ich sag mal vielen Dank. Ich denke jetzt haben wir hier einen
Überblick gewonnen oder gibt es noch irgendetwas, was du uns mit auf den Weg
geben möchtest, was wir noch nicht so angesprochen haben?
Ne, ne, das hat mir total viel Spaß gemacht. Wir sind ja wirklich durch alles
einmal durchgegangen, was ich hier so mache. Sehr schön. Ich fand's sehr schön.
Vorrang. Gut, dann vielen Dank.
Und ja, vielen Dank für's Zuhören, das war's von mir von Raumzeit.
Ihr wisst, bald geht's wieder weiter. Bis dahin sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.